boom and we're live right so why is it
then when people start getting like
super spiritual they start dressing like
you you dress like a guru we circulate a
memo so it's now time to stop wearing
socks stop shaving and make eye contact
for a bit too long it doesn't cost a
buck staring how long I'm gonna go with
the beard I mean that's that's like your
full-on like you're a yogi now I mean
it's gone beyond Jesus and into Moses
and lesser prophets worse or a Navy SEAL
you're in that range - he could be some
wild man that's that's a mistake that
wouldn't hurt like if there was an
assault course in front of us that the
potential for movie in a Navy SEAL would
start to break down at once went on a an
assault course with some US Marines in
that place near San Diego the name of
that base and climbing up that rope
using your leg muscles it was not good
value and enjoy it I like the
camaraderie and I really like I as I've
written about and talked about quite a
lot when I'm around very in very male
environment I kind of really like it I
really get off on it but I have to watch
myself not getting too excitable it's
even in this environment as a matter of
fact I have to keep myself a little bit
chilled out why would even words adieu
dear well I guess what is my early life
I grew up mostly around my mum and I
don't have brothers and sisters and
stuff like that so my male role modeling
occurred later in life and I think
probably relates to this spiritual thing
I think it meant that I was very open to
sort of spiritual experience meditative
experience I didn't have a lot of
grounding physical experiences or bodily
experiences really till adolescence
until sick and sexuality that's the
first time I really got into the body
didn't do spore as a kid didn't have
like men going right this is what we do
this is how we shave this is how you
dream people this is you know I don't
really get that kind of education so now
still if I'm around like soldiers UFC
fighters I go you know you know I do BJJ
merrily as a result of these conference
where there's not calm confrontation so
like I there's a bit of me that's the
guy I get excited about in
of it it's not homoerotic because that
doesn't happen to be the way that I roll
out just enjoy a little too much there's
something about it and it may be what's
bad about it what's what's bad about
getting fired up nothing for me except
like you know look my as you know my
model for life is a sort of a 12-step
model about watching my impulses my
impulses have got me in a lot of trouble
my impulses to take drugs my impulses to
sleep around my like my impulses to even
eat food I've got a tendency to get
obsessive but you know you would
probably argue that if you direct that
energy correctly it can be kind of
positive I think it can but I agree with
you that it can get out of control and I
have similar impulses I have similar
problems and I've just used discipline
and hard work especially working out to
try to mitigate it well that's what I
pick up from you is that your early
encounters with martial arts of men
you've understood from a young age it
seems to me physical discipline and I
think that's a very important thing and
I'm only learning that like now because
I've had a like you know drugs then Fame
there are none chaos and I've only just
emerge from like this of the fog of that
madness I love how you've emerged though
because it's very unique you you you've
uniquely emerged authentically like you
this is who you really are like you're
not putting on an act you found yourself
which is like what everybody wants to do
they want to find themselves I mean it
never feels like a completed task right
and everyone's a work in progress
forever that's why but you are you like
you are very comfortably you and you've
found what makes you you that's a lovely
compliment to get from you Joe I
appreciate that because what I think
about is like you're a very different
type of person to me there's things that
in this world in these polemical times
you and I would be supposed to I would
say take adversarial stances on I'm
vegan now you love hunting but my
personal philosophy is my morality and
my spirituality is for me it's not
something I'd go around inflicting on
other people and telling them how they
should behave either
I know enough now to know people are
different people have different
experiences and I don't let those things
get in the way of how I evaluate other
people we should all be more like that I
really I really believe that I mean
there's so many people that I disagree
with that I have fine conversations with
I don't think there's anything wrong
with that and I don't think that impulse
to have antagonistic engagements with
people that you disagree with is correct
how else are we going to consolidate
yeah if like it's just like I'm only
gonna deal with people that see the
world roughly how I do how will weaken
and form new tribes new alliances new
relationships new systems at a time when
evidently it feels to me at least Joe
died things are breaking down yeah
there's a lot bitterness acerbity and
confrontation and people don't want to
talk to each other I mean I don't know
how real that is of actual people I'm
talking I suppose about how the media
landscape seems to present information I
don't know if that's true when you're
you know when I'm around people I don't
sense
oh wow these guys are really tied up in
brexit or crumpled it doesn't seem that
relevant to ordinary people it seems to
me that people are still operating on a
in a personal how are you today you know
people are willing to get on like that I
mean how we supposed to take these ideas
on board it's almost too vast for us
geopolitical ideas that we're asked to
identify with right and then your
everyday life it hardly ever affects you
or affects you very little in comparison
to things that you ignore because you're
concentrating on brexit are you
concentrating on Trump or you're
concentrating on whatever it is ya build
that wall whatever it is yeah I start to
wonder yo who is it that's involved in
this stuff I starts at what it's where
I'm at now is are we even capable of
belonging to groups units tribes of 300
million people or 60 million people with
so many diverse ideas is this a time to
look at federalism differently to start
breaking down well you know the eye
exists within this tribe of people but I
collaborate with all these other people
I don't know how municipal action gets
done and there you run an army and build
roads if people are starting to operate
in smaller units but I am thinking that
we need to have a real sense of
community and connection and we got to
let go of looking for ways to object to
and judge other people was some sort
before wire forming our own identity no
I completely agree and I think we're
probably moving towards some sort of
understanding that a lot of these
boundaries and these clans of you know
states and countries they were all
established without our consent before
we were born and we're just we're a part
of a system that we just were we didn't
agree to it we just all of a sudden
found ourselves in it and we're trying
to make it fit us yeah that's right and
there's aspects of it that are appealing
you know likes of during a World Cup
I've really strongly all English and
Ferrara you know like I feel with
genuine census prevention and investment
but if I'm being asked to live according
a rules that don't affect me that except
for you know that perfectly financially
and don't speak to who I am as an
individual within I'm like what is this
this is my benefit yeah yeah when the
the inclination to form teams and to
root for your team and a route against
other teams it's it's so deep seeded in
us it's and it can cause so many
unnecessary conflicts for no reason it's
just it's it's so it's so escapable too
it's it's somewhat so if you can
objectively analyze the way human beings
behave and interact with each other and
go well why do we do this
let's just stop doing that let's just if
we disagree on things how much are these
disagreements actually affecting me on a
daily basis not that much
can we just communicate can't someone
say what they think and I say what I
think and we just decide like what makes
sense and what doesn't make sense based
on our own interpretations it seems like
it's that's the direction we go ahead in
I did as I know you have done a podcast
with Candice Owens who like on the
subject of you know individuals like
when she says stuff like a people should
get over slavery or it says if it didn't
have and I don't agree with that I feel
like that has a massive social impact
that is that those statistics and not
come incidents the number of people are
certain ethnicities in prisons and in
poverty or whatever for me that's not
just the coincidence but as I said I
couldn't agree with her more profoundly
on according to social criteria from
very very important issues on in
personal level of which she was
absolutely delightful that's so funny
and sweet and she's very young if you
really start with English at Lascaux
she's only 28 which is amazing right
she's so much smarter than I was when I
was 28 she sent me a lot more confident
no she's prettier too plain 28 or 29
same thing so when I was 29 I was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay and no one would ever
listen to my opinions on anything in on
a world stage yeah people were listening
to her I mean she's she's testifying in
front of Congress I mean she's so I cut
her a lot of slack with some of the
things that she's made like missteps on
and I think sometimes when people say
those things like people should get over
slavery it's like it's almost like
you're saying things that you think
other people want to hear more than
you're saying things that are really
rational so whether or not we should get
over slavery sure slavery was over more
than a hundred years ago but the
repercussions of slavery the echoes of
slavery still exist and they exist in
all these different southern states and
cities and all these different
neighborhoods that had been a part of
systemic racism where they had literally
forced black people to live in certain
areas and didn't even allow them to buy
homes outside of those areas they made
laws and those laws are in place in
places like Baltimore and you know I had
this guy Michael Wood on who was a
police officer in the city of Baltimore
and one of the more profound things that
he said was that they found papers that
were documenting crimes from the 1970s
in Baltimore and they were in this same
area the same crimes that he was facing
in the 2000s when he was a police
officer so he was looking at this going
what in the [ __ ] like this is am I just
a part of something that's never gonna
be fixed and never gonna be changed and
you know as he learned more about the
city in the city's laws and how these
these systems were set up to keep people
in certain places and how the crime and
the violence and the drugs is all just
in this one concentrated area and it's
always been there and no one does
anything to change it yeah you realize
like wow this is a this is a crazy echo
of a horrible past and that's what it is
I had a cop
of conversations that made me recognize
how powerful systems and institutions
are and their ability to maintain
themselves regardless of any individuals
it seems like what happened there with
the man you were chatting to is that
he's an individual woke up oh my god
hold on a second in some sort of weird
grid and like I suppose this fella
called Kinross who worked for the
British Diplomatic Service at the time
of 9/11 and was privy to confidential
information about how that was handled
on a military and geopolitical level and
he said like he's come away from that
thinking well these institutions
function and in a totally corrupt way to
pursue their own objectives this
ingenuity and dishonesty is just part of
the system and it was him that made me
think about anarchism in a different way
saying that people the assumption that
people if you they were not tightly
governed with big government and huge
control would grammar jury in each other
and raping each other simply not true
that's one of the means by which the
state continues to justify its existence
people will behave better the closer
they are to self-governing communities
self-governing community sitll and I was
interested in that because he's talking
from this is what I saw on the inside
this is how I saw it was running like
your cop friend there and like another
person I spoke to that had been inside a
system
and then woken up within it who was that
Yanis varoufakis he was when Greece had
that mad revolution he was like one of
the leaders of a party sir it sir and
for a minute it was like cerise I said
we ain't paying back all those debts you
screwed us financially you've screwed
Greece so he was there at the EU meeting
telling like the German Chancellery
we're not part Greece ain't gonna repay
those debts and he just said that the
way that the system reassured itself was
magnificent to watch in a way and he
said none of those individuals have any
power except the power that that role
gives them if you are the German Finance
Minister you've got the power that
German Finance Minister has you can't
step outside it and start going right
this and why don't we do this and why
don't we do that the system itself is
beyond individual decisions you know
it's it's a self-sustaining system it
won't come up with ideas or support
ideas that threaten it and that's why I
continually keep hearing and I'm sure
you're having similar conversations that
if you are really interested in changing
the world you
the participating systems there outside
of it set up new ideas don't worry about
trying to smash this one down with a
hammer it will atrophy on its own as you
know it comes less and less relevant I
think also change yourself and when you
change yourself becomes evident to the
people around you and if your change is
beneficial and attractive people they
gravitate towards that idea that you can
improve yourself and you can you change
the your perspective on things
well that is the one area of your life
where you've got some Authority in
control and that's yeah that is what I'm
about is like that well I can't stop
myself being like a watching pornography
I can stop myself using drugs if I want
to like you know with some support and
that's what that this book it mentors
which I talked about you in only four
paragraph you know I mean it's not too
it's not like of like literary fellatio
it's a small nod of your like of your
influence in impact I talked about how
we have latent latent qualities within
us that are sometimes hard to realize on
on without support but if you find a
mentor in an area where you're looking
to improve they can kind of energize
awaken energies within you that on your
own you wouldn't be able to use I had a
really recent experience of it where I'm
sort of like freaking out about
something I spoke to like a mentor of
mine and like the way the East or spoke
to me was like sort of aggressive like I
sort of an aggressive that's not gonna
happen you are not afraid and like it
sort of it woke up the part of me then
it feels that way that has that kind of
I would say sort of male certainty a
kind of grounded energy he was able to
sort of like direct at me and like in
that moment in myself all bewildered I
wasn't able to do it you know it needed
to resource it externally in a moment so
this is how I still feel like your
individual journey I'm interested in how
cuz I'm guessing with your background in
martial arts and stuff mentorship seems
pretty much stitched into that you must
continually be looking at someone
learning from someone trying to equal
them or whatever it is yeah the good
part about that is you get good at
learning things you get good at
listening
No as a martial art student you you
don't just listen you listen very
intently you bow you say sir you know I
mean there's there's so much discipline
involved in the the act of learning yeah
and so much reverence and respect for
people no more than you in appreciation
so that that helped me with pretty much
everything I ever wanted to learn I just
would listen very intently and I don't
think maybe I could figure it out better
I'm very good at listening to people
that are good at things that's
interesting did you first get into like
you know picked up stuff over the
various shows that of yours that I've
listened to but would you say that your
inaugural interest in martial arts came
from kind of domestic distress and stuff
at a difficult home life and not a good
relation with your stepdad am i right
instead it was there but it was was also
moved moving more than anything I mean
all my stepdads a nice guy
but it was stepdads it's always a weird
situation you know no one likes the
dynamic of someone having sex with their
mother I remember I don't want to like
navcore pain him in a bad way that's
just what was really hard was moving a
lot and running into bullies that was
way harder than anything else so there
was a time in your life where you felt
very presumably vulnerable yeah and not
grounded didn't have any friends
constantly moving in new neighborhoods
meeting new people and you know and when
you're a young boy you're a teenage boy
teenage boys are [ __ ] dangerous
yeah the worse they're the worst you see
a group of them now I'm talking about my
country for in 14 years old are across
the street yeah lawless well young boys
are just they're always looking to
impress each other and they have these
if you want to find real toxic
masculinity it exists in teenage boys
yeah it's mostly saturated in men the
way it's described it's mostly
exaggerated in terms of the way the
media talks about it but it in its
purest form and teenage boys they get
together and they start lighting frogs
on fire and doing [ __ ] they do things
because they want to like one-up each
other and they feed off of each other
like what one boy would do is so
different than what five boys would do
what
five boys would do who could be horrific
but one boy would do on his own it's
very rarely there because what you know
you have to think about yourself and
think about is this right and you
objectively analyze the way you're
behaving and like um yeah people
wouldn't be proud of me if I did it this
way when you're with five other boys and
you're you're all rambunctious and
filled with testosterone and piss and
vinegar you wind up doing crazy things
this is I you know we're not here
something like that is didn't know to
think that it's of course relative
relative to us the behavior of
adolescent mouse is reckless and crazy
it's not impossible to conceive of an
intelligent that would look at the
behavior of adult human beings and think
oh my god yeah what's governing these
people what principles are they using
right like what's the end goal to what
are you trying to accomplish with your
life with your existence with your time
I think if there's a real concern about
AI I think the real concern is AI is
gonna rationally analyze our behavior
and our reliance on emotions and all
these human reward systems that we have
built in the way it's affecting our
society and the way it's affecting how
we govern ourselves and how we behave
amongst ourselves and it's gonna think
we're unfixable it's gonna look at it
like well this is this is a they have
too much monkey in them they have so
much monkey instincts and monkey DNA but
now they live in this rational modern
world of you know 5g internet on your
phone and satellite communication and
24/7 news cycle but yet they have these
primate genes official intelligence a
subject about which I know very little
it seems to me that you will on some
level have to be derived from a
particular aspect of human understanding
and rationalism so we're representing
one aspect of our nature and
prioritizing it logic organization but
what you refer to is sort of primitive
and monkey ish for me it envelops and
involves the most beautiful aspects of
our nature I'm a little romantic about
human being still I still feel that I
feel that one of the great problems
we've
is that philosophically we have
overvalued materialism rationalism and
like Univ knowing a little bit about
philosophy primarily from that bloody
podcast that you and I tagged a minute
ago before we was recording last was
this so like what why I understand for
that is that post enlightenment we've
started to prioritize rationalism so if
you prioritize rationalism and
organization which obviously has a lot
to offer the organization of resources
is incredibly and hugely important you
forget that a huge part of the human
experience is nothing to do with that
the other thing we were champ out before
we went live was DMT now no artificial
intelligence is gonna understand that
there is access to a realm of
consciousness that continually exists
that doesn't seem to be bound by
physical laws as we understand them and
if the physical laws that we abide by
are parochial and relevant only to this
level of existence why are we allowing
ideas resourced from there to govern all
of our systems you know even listen to
you talk about the empty nine count at
these gestures I they're jesters I went
through this membrane into another realm
and checking out Mike Tyson when he was
on here yeah I took acid when I was a
teenager and even in very unhealthy can
I help about blood and bridled mad
teenage boy conditions I you know I'm
gonna be there with a guy in a lab coat
with a pen going well mr. brand sit down
look at these Rorschach tests stead of
which I'm in New Cross in a bedsit
dropping acid and staring at my own
hands and recognizing oh my god I'm not
me the very idea of me is a construct
I'm just tuned into a particular aspect
I I will build systems that are
predicated on rationalism organization
and I on that basis I can see why they
would at some point here go all Skynet
and annihilate us but that is a I
believe the problem with our society is
that the materialistic aspect of our
nature is not the priority it's just one
thing we should be doing cause we need
good roads cause many hospitals schools
food etc but we need to find a way of
honoring the sacred
I'm fascinated in the experiences you're
having in these psychedelic explorations
and how its influencing the rest of your
life like how you're saying like how
you're how does it influence the rest of
your decisions the way you see the world
the way you see relationships the way
you see the vulnerable young man you
were prior to building your own I say
personal religion of martial arts
excellence in your chosen field of
stand-up comedy how do you incorporate
that vulnerable kid because I'm still
very aware of the vulnerable person I
was and like I'm going on a rant man
like when Kevin Hart was on here who I
think he's amazing and he was amazing on
this I fought [ __ ] hell like what
have I got to offer in a world when
Kevin Hart has got this kind of force oh
yeah you don't come in the bubble and I
was like my god this guy's so positive
what a role model well he's got to offer
and then I thought well like any of us
what I've got to offer is Who I am
just Who I am and then vulnerable flawed
human being the steel feels connected to
the kid I was when I didn't feel good
enough I still feel that I can walk in a
room and feel that you know I also know
that that's that's not real because I've
had spiritual experiences Hallucigenia
experiences that make me feel that the
relationships we should be building have
to honor that we are both we're
vulnerable and flawed but also capable
of greatness there has to be room for
all of this and I feel that part of what
we're doing and part of why we're
experiencing such superficial polarity
in politics and culture is because we're
not acknowledging that underneath this
surface activity of left right left
right and you know from Sam Harris them
little experiments you stick garbage in
front of a purse I'm on there they
become Republican pretty quickly or you
know you scare people they become less
democratic you know I think all that
stuff is pretty superficial and at depth
in that realm of the jesters and the
membrane of psychedelia we have access
to oneness and that should be what's
influencing the way we set up our tribes
our systems and our relationships yeah I
think when a guy like Kevin Hart shows
you what a positive and motivational
impact one person can have just with his
words and his deeds and the way he lives
his life he's so inspirational that you
realize that that that is possible that
you can share
energy and that you can have these
experiences with people where they
literally do actually they actually
uplift you like I like was uplifted by
his conversation I felt like wow that
guy is so positive what a great way to
look at the life that we're living and
the more people do that the better and
when someone like that does spread a
positive message you know and obviously
he's got he's materialistic as well he's
got a bunch of cars in a big house and
he makes a lot of money and he does a
lot of movies but what he's spreading is
this very motivational very positive
message and that affects people in a
very positive way too and all that
left-right [ __ ] and all this all of the
battles that we have politically and
ideologically back and forth and all the
negative venom that people spray at each
other at the end of the day that this is
not benefiting anyone unless you're
fighting some major demon that the world
needs to conquer and most of that most
of it's not that most of it is like
finding demons that have innocuous
things you know and I think when you
talk about what what you have to offer
what you have to offer is that you are
you that you have this unique
perspective you you can affect the way
people view their own journey in life
because you've been so introspective and
so aware of your own pros and cons in
terms of your past behavior your current
behavior and who you are now and who you
used to be all that stuff is fuel for
people because they can relate they hear
it I mean maybe they cannot relate to
being a movie star and being this famous
guy and the strut but they can relate to
the humanity of your struggle they put
themselves in your position like what
must that have been like and look at
this guy who's made these conscious
decisions to not be like that anymore
and he dresses like a homeless person
with a crazy beard that's the real take
home information dress like you live out
of doors
yeah just like you're a homeless guy in
Oregon people respect that yeah it's
like dark colors you know rains Allah
okay I get the reference I understand
American culture token
yeah so um hey can I do some for like ya
t tell me what it's called what is it
this book is called mentors and actually
I really like I read it bits of it again
because I knew I was coming here and I
think he's actually pretty good like I
wrote quite a lot about Brazilian
Jujitsu really love it yeah do my
writing is not from you'll understand
not from a technical perspective I'm not
saying this is what I've got to say on
open guard transition I'm talking about
how the psychological impact that it's
had on me and also in there about like
the protocols have going to a group
which as a beginner are very relevant
like you touched on how ritualized it is
I got a hunch that they're more we
emulate and connect to original ways of
human behavior whether that's dietary or
hierarchies or organization of groups I
feel that we will feel the sense of
greater connection now the thing I got
from the gun in BJJ class is Genesis
where I go in back in England it's like
that all the white belts get changed at
one end of the room the purple belts and
above get changed at the other end of
the room which coincidentally or not is
where the control for the timer is and
the control for the music is and where
the kit is that's all up that rooms at
end of the room so all the control is
that end that it begins we've sort of
dancing around in a circle doing all of
those various exercises now lift your
knees now do the shrimp in and that kind
of stuff it's the lower belt shouldn't
invite a higher Bell to spa or roll you
know it's at and like the as you say the
amount of respect the bowing the
handshaking and the end of it it's so
soft it provides such a safe environment
in which to deal with the primal I can
see why it's valuable and it's there
like you know I should have been taught
that [ __ ] when I was 14 13 like as
Amanda Tara Lee so that I didn't come
across it like you know you're not gonna
be setting fire to fields and allotments
and putting frogs on fireworks if you've
got a way of dealing with that primal
energy yeah when when it's coming some
people they don't understand that think
that you should suppress it somehow you
should just ignore it or suppress it
they don't understand that one man
they're really a biological male at
needs to be tackled head-on I mean you
really really need to embrace what it is
to be a physical male and it frees you
in a lot of ways do you think this might
be a comparable moment to in the 1960s
when there was a sort of a sense of
sexual repression versus sexual free
laughs you know the images of Woodstock
and flowers in their hair and smoking
joints and having sort of sex outdoors
in mud or possibly wheat but this time
of like a kind of an anger about male
nurse
you know and maleness may not as you
said it might be a biological male but
it could be the energy of I don't know
assertion or wherever these like you
know as in grammar your male and female
relate to certain words as in French
grammar where I don't know cat is female
and doggies now I don't know the system
I don't speak French but I'm saying that
these we have labeled these energies and
it does seem that that there is a
particular what I want to say a
condemnation of male energy
do you think you can come from a
misunderstanding yeah and I also think
it comes from a big generalization -
yeah it's easy to do right and if you're
a woman who's had negative experiences
with man maybe you've dated men that
have been physically abusive or maybe
you've known men that have been
physically abusive and you're around
that and you just it's it's very
convenient and very easy to just
generalize and decide that all men are
negative yeah masculine energy is
negative and especially white males and
if you say that you'll get props online
people go yes girl yes clap clap clap
people get excited but those are also
people that are short-sighted like you
want to make as many people your ally as
you can you want to make as many people
your friend as you can and you have to
understand that there's some people that
are just wired different than you
there's some there's some girly girls
and there's some really feminine men and
then there's some masculine man and then
in it but everybody is okay as long as
they respect you and they're kind to
each other
but the problem is we associate certain
behaviors and characteristics with
either negativity or hedonism or toxic
masculinity or someone being a [ __ ] as
a man and that's these generalizations
are often way more harmful and just it's
just too convenient and easy and lays
there is no simple way and when I think
about my own attitudes in this area
there is a degree of complexity because
I've got young daughters I've got a
two-year-old and a one-year-old right
and there you know daughters so like but
when the other day because I'm staying
in Los Angeles Gaby she's Mexican she's
two when I first moved out here and
lived my entourage lifestyle she used to
look after the house and she used to
think oh my baby my baby she loved me so
tonight like I'll take her matriarchal
figure wherever I can find one and Gaby
used to look after me she adored me and
stuff I stayed friends well yesterday
she come around
she bought like like what can only
describe as a bikini for like my baby
daughter like that what a two-year-old
that doesn't need like a bikini like top
and I excuse me burping on the mic I
like it for me I thought I don't want to
put my daughter in that that's sort of
in a way it's sexualizing the like that
child and like cover so and also a lot
that like with my daughter
I don't like with my wife particularly
our first child I don't dress her up in
little dresses and stuff because she
won't be out of run around and I thought
my god I'm not that's not that different
from like the cliche of a male parent
that one in a son and I didn't want to
sign or be known particular I've loved
this kid I love this kid regarding you
know it doesn't mean I love for having
the door adore her but like I am aware
that these things have like dress a
child this way dress a girl this way are
constructs further to what we were
talking about game before bat Michele
Foucault we got a lot done before we
went live man we moved to Michel
Foucault what he exposes a lot is that
there and a deluge guild Gilda lose is
that a lot of things that we take for
granted as being normal or actually
constructs and when I say a child's
bikini there's no reason for any child
of any sex or gender to be wearing a
bloody bikini so a child with tits is a
terrifying idea for all but a very small
and terrifying percentage of the
population so like that is an example of
the external feminization of a child
like so when there's an argument a
feminist argument of you know Jen there
is a construct I can see oh yeah it's a
point it is there is there are
constructs like my opinion is you can't
argue with biology chromosomes are doing
what they're doing in the physical real
but like you know like have been a
father to a daughter has made me feel
like I don't obviously and then you have
daughters or at least they thought
through three daughters like I like I'm
certainly very aware of I don't want to
push them down some culturally
prescribed Avenue whether it's men they
dress their sexuality or anything so
I've got you know where do I where am I
on that dial you know yeah you got a
just not put any pressure on them and
let them enjoy their life and let them
find their path that's whether it's
what's weird right it's like I see
people they're you know they're getting
their their daughters to dress very very
feminine with a little mini skirts and
stuff when they're five years old and
high-heeled shoes I've seen little kids
with high-heeled shoes his name's very
strange to me I don't like it
yeah what so you know but for me that is
being sourced from like can't we can
extrapolate that to but then why should
a 20 year old woman wear high heels I
mean I've read cultural analysis I'm
sure you have of law well the lipstick
is to emphasize the lips because it's an
redolent of the vagina the high heels is
to make a woman seem more vulnerable and
to accentuate aspects of body shape now
this can be you know seen as evidence of
the influence of patriarchy know that
there's loads of areas where I feel like
why are we looking for [ __ ] to argue
about in this area we're just human
beings most of us and most important
people in our life of the earth
different gender or sex to us you know
why we live for arguments but I can you
can see the influence of cultural forces
that are you know not neutral yeah you
certainly can but I think it should be
up to the choice of the person once
they're an adult
the real problem is putting pressure on
them to dress one way or another and not
letting them find their place but if a
woman becomes you know whatever age you
decide and she wants to wear high heels
and a skirt cuz she likes the way it
looks like there's nothing wrong with
that either and our our the demonization
of sexuality is also a problem you know
yes it is almost as much of a problem as
people who will pray upon vulnerable
people the people people that think
there's something wrong with being
sexually attractive or something wrong
with being desirable or wanting to be
desirable something
with that either and that kind of
suppression the suppression of these
feelings that you have in this desire
that you have it's very unhealthy as
well it's a normal thing to want to be
sexual it's a normal thing to want to
look good if a girl looks good in a
skirt skirt and high heels and she likes
to dress like that who the [ __ ] is
anyone to say there's anything wrong
with that there's nothing wrong with it
it's if that's what she likes that's
fine which is it what's interesting to
me is particularly in really progressive
ideology they looked down upon women who
wear short skirts and high heels and a
lot of makeup and you know open tops
that show their boobs because they think
that it's they're playing into the
patriarchy or that there's somehow or
another
falling into these gender traps but yet
they celebrate that in transgender
people they celebrate that in trans men
that transition to women and then they
they they really doll it up then they're
like you go girl then they're
celebrating the fact that this person is
embracing these traditional aspects of
womanhood like well you see that a lot
with you know people that are
celebrating trans women so I'm very
fascinated the aesthetics of the sort of
what would be perhaps could be referred
to as sexualized
dress more like a I suppose in males
expression expressive or garish clothing
jewelry tattoos in I understand in
British culture that these are often
indicators of class that like that it's
typically the lower down the class
structure you are the more likely you
are to dress in a way that is exhibit if
or like you know women from a
blue-collar background dress in ways
that are exposing and revealing men have
leery cars and lots of tattoos and
jewelry
expressive ways of demonstrating wealth
the higher you go up the class the more
subtle more dress down you know labels
all that slight stuff you know so in
British culture there's a different
system of like a different system for
referencing it I wonder how that works
in American culture with it's sort of
like it's evident and much disgust
racial divisions like certain things it
seems like a subtle way of condemning
Killa types of womanhood that may not
just be sourced from dressed this way
for the male gaze it can also be a way
of saying dressing that way is an
indication of a lower-class background
or of a particular type of ethnicity but
there's also the reality of males and
females as there's a lot of [ __ ]
jealous people and there's a lot of
women that just don't have the type of
physical body that looks good in a short
skirt with high heels and you know a
low-cut shirt and they don't like when
they see it in other women because they
don't they're not comfortable with their
own bodies there's a reality of that I
mean women get as much or more hate from
women as they ever do for men and
particularly if women find you to be too
overtly sexual with the way you dress or
behave that you're you're you know
you're damaging male-female
relationships you're damaging the
dynamic particular office dynamics if
there's one girl in the office that
likes to [ __ ] it up you know and she's
and all the guys are paying attention to
her women will get mad at her I did an
interview while ago where sort of talks
about like parent in our kids me and my
wife how we parent our kids and I said
like you know guys I have to be honest
my wife is much the more dominant parent
she's much more practical than I am
right and like stuff that got that got
like really negatively written about
people said like like oh she changes
more diapers than I do and stuff right
but not like like don't change diapers
away but it's just my wife you know
regardless of our respective sexes is
the more efficient dominant parent she's
much more likely with like with me if my
dog goes I want that chocolate the
answer to me all right you know like I
can't bear a see the the resistance the
emotional explosion I concede much too
early I tap out very quickly with my
two-year-old my wife is much more know
that's played a long game that's bring
up a child that's not government my
impulses like you and I spoke in fact to
that gap or Matt a that Expo and
addiction he's amazing and he says
because of your own anxiety and pain
from your own childhood we've no
disrespect to my magnificent parents
like you can't handle seeing your kids
suffer so you like straight away you
bail and do what she wants and stuff now
they of like so
so much complexity in the reality of our
personal little domestic relationship
I'm certainly we're not saying and
everyone else should run their household
in that manner as well and so help me
God
any man that changes it you know but the
way it's reported is like that's what
happens I think in modern media is they
change what you say then you have to
defend what they said you said and you
know that ain't what I meant I'd like
you know I'm not saying that because my
wife is a woman she should take more
domestic you know I'm just saying that
in our household she seems to have a set
of attributes and characteristics that
make her a take control of that aspect
of parenting and it's like the the
desire to judge condemn an object is the
priority as opposed that you know no
one's looking to go okay as well where
you know well it's also that they're
doing it publicly so they're doing it
most
I mean if you're you either reading
comments or you're reading articles and
if you're reading articles they're just
looking for something to be upset about
they watch you and they'll say okay is
this a viable target yes we got
confirmation what he said about changing
diapers or his wife being a better
parent is a viable target let's go after
them and then they just formulate some
[ __ ] argument about who you really
are based on what might have been a
throwaway
or a concession to your wife or even
just a compliment to your wife soaking
them in self-deprecating yeah but
doesn't people know they're not looking
at things rationally they're just
looking at targets particularly people
that write articles you know what's the
best article it's got to be negative
like one of the things that came out of
all this Facebook algorithm stuff is you
find out that Facebook realized
somewhere early on that the way to
encourage engagement is to get people
upset they they get way more engaged and
they go back and forth and and inter
interact with these posts way more if
they're upset than they do if they agree
with it if they agree with it they might
give it a like or a thumbs up and say
hey that's great and that's it that's
where it ends but if you know someone's
talking about you know we shouldn't
build the wall we should let everyone in
and you put that on some [ __ ] Trump
guy's page and they it's crazy I mean
you will get thousands and thousands and
thousands of interactions and so
Facebook realized that the way to keep
people and you know they could claim
that it's an algorithm and the algorithm
just supports whatever the people are
really interests
but what they're interested in this
conflict that demonstrates my earlier
point which I made up on the spot
the AI is not a neutral thing it is
resourced from human perspectives and
because that is a type of AI from those
knowledge complexes what we're going to
experience and I can't even imagine but
what I'm saying is is it still darkness
a resourced from a human from a human
perspective and yes of course we are
evolved to respond more strongly to
negativity than positivity for loads of
reasons and I think that's where we can
stitch back to what we were saying about
taking personal responsibility through
you are like that none of us after sit
on social media going [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
are here none of us have to do that we
can try and resolve though I respect
that some people don't have any other
outlets they don't have the privileges I
have of being out go support groups
where people openly talk about this is
the ways that I felt inferior today this
is the ways that I'm trying to become a
better man and a better father and a
better coworker you know like a lot of
people aren't afforded those
environments and probably the best shot
they got is having a go that was someone
online and those people you know in a
way deserve love and sympathy but until
we on some level recognize that we can
all our own behaviors we can all are our
own consciousness all right I don't see
how there's going to be well at least
then we can create a terrain upon which
a better better systems can start to
flourish
do you read comments no I actually like
to sense if I can just about manage to
listen to people's replies to my
conversation like you know like sort
like yeah I don't go on like I have like
I work with someone who doesn't my
social media and like she gives me stuff
like here I'll respond to these things
put some output on that because I don't
I don't want to engage with that I don't
you know like walk up and down any
Street knocking on the door go and do
you like me do you like me don't deal
with people's responses in various
conditions well it's also much like the
articles but the way people get a
response out of you or the way to people
to get your reaction is to say something
really negative you look at some
sometimes when people are not that savvy
when it comes to social media one things
one of the things that you'll notice is
they'll interact and I've been guilty of
this in the past but
for I sort of realized what I was doing
you would only respond to negative
things like people are arguing the
people meanwhile people are saying nice
things to you and you ignore them yeah
it's cuz you don't you don't you at a
certain level you don't have the
physical time it doesn't exist to
respond to everyone it's not possible
there's no if you get 13,000 comments on
one of your posts how the [ __ ] does
anyone have time to respond to 13,000
people you can't and then you have email
and you have Twitter and Facebook and
Instagram and just there's no way it's
there's not enough time in this world so
you would potentially would have
responded to things that cause them or
they said if I saw someone saying
something was untrue but [ __ ] you that's
untrue but then I realize like what do
you why yeah you're doing like this is a
new thing for people there's never been
a time where people have had this
instantaneous interaction with people
unfiltered unmoderated globally yeah and
it's very strange to be able to do that
and to be able to go back and forth and
just just to be able to give your
comments on things to be able to talk
about things it's very addictive to
people yeah that's right and that's why
I'm very cautious with it I have this
officer my life out like I'm essentially
a monk in a marriage that's basically I
live get up meditate do yoga do
exercises do things that are positive
for you watch the way that you're
thinking I'm interested in where again
in with your own do you feel connected
to the person you were as an adolescent
do you notice it in your own parent in
do you notice it in the type of choices
you make because the image I have a view
from the outside is like that you have
literally built something for yourself
you operate within it and you are quite
protected and you are independent and
not forced to deal with too many
negative outside influences but in
unavoidable dynamics that unnecessary
dynamics like you know as a father and
dealing with colleagues and stuff like
that do you experience a lot of tension
anxiety
what what what has happened to that guy
do you feel that you have transcended
that because I do in my own life feel
like yeah I'm not the adolescent boy I
was I've like you know I've learned from
that and I still in a various of cod
psychological way you know when I'm
doing
that's the JJJ classes I'm doing over
here we have known professor Ricardo
will keep amazing guy like what when I'm
when I'm doing those classes I have a
cut a sense of fathering my child self
of mine you know because I weren't doing
those kind of things when I was a kid
I'm like it's alright rascal we're just
in a BJJ class to impress anybody right
if you don't know just ask I've got a
voice in myself because I checked a Tony
Robbins you know he's like never
obviously high achieving guy who I
respect a great deal and like you know
when he talks he does like these cold
plunges and he says before I get in that
project you're getting in that [ __ ]
punch my god I don't talk to myself like
right Russell we're gonna get in the
cold plunge we're gonna really what are
you doing with that aspect of yourself
do you still have a relationship with it
how is it like when you're doing all
these psychedelic cosmonaut ik
explorations of the psyche
are you not encountering aspects of
yourself that are an undeveloped
unaddressed there's always going to be
unaddressed and undeveloped aspects of
yourself but I'm very very very
different to who I was when I was a
young boy I mean I'm I'm not a hundred
percent self actualize I don't think
anybody is but I'm just a totally
different human being I remember it but
I remember it with humor
like I remember I laugh I'm like wow so
silly I was so weird back then and you
know with life experience and developing
confidence and understanding of who you
are and why you had those feelings and
why you were insecure and why he had so
much self-doubt martial arts helped me
with that with that tremendously because
it was the first thing that I ever did
where I didn't feel like a loser so the
first thing that I ever did were people
like respected me and they liked me for
it
you know I'm like wow this is like some
was a feeling that I was completely
unused to in the 14 previous years of my
life all of a sudden there was this this
feeling that I was unusual I was unique
I was special wow you know I was
appreciated you were good at quick yeah
I was I had a natural inclination
towards it and I was obsessed with it so
I was obsessed with it so straining
every day all day long and then my
instructor recognized it really early on
so he allowed me to train there for free
and just I would teach classes and
teaching classes helped me a lot as well
because when you're teaching you're
breaking down techniques and your you
you when you're showing someone how to
do it you're really cementing those
pathways in your own mind yeah yeah
that's right that must be an important
step on the road to mastery I see that
clip where Eddie Bravo gave you your
black belt and you were very moved by
that like so for me that like moments
like that it must connect you to the
beginning of the journey yeah that does
yeah for sure and what's still you know
the journey of jiu-jitsu is a
fascinating one because unless you're
someone who's you know a saalu ribeiro
or a John Jacques Machado or just a true
master who has dedicated their entire
life to it the journey so long it's so
long it's like if you're a guy who runs
you like to run I like to run a mile
three or four days a week no big deal
but then you know your next-door
neighbor's an ultra marathon runner is
preparing for them the Moab 240 where
he's gonna run 240 miles
you're just you're never gonna catch up
the same amount of times and you should
always defer to that person when you
have questions about running and that's
how it is with jiu-jitsu like is you
know yeah I'm a black belt but I'm not a
black belt like John Jacques Machado I
was a black belt is there's levels to
even to that so I always have questions
so the journey is never over it's always
long there's always a better way to get
out of an armbar or a better way to set
up a triangle or whatever it is there's
the one of the beautiful things about
Jiu Jitsu is that it's so complex
there's so many variables there's so
many situations and interactions and
exchanges and entries and defenses and
and and wait a chain moves together and
the correct way to set something up to
three steps ahead to know that if you
grab the repel this way the guy's gonna
try to shake it off that way and that
exposes this which exposes that and then
the next defense will expose this and
then you keep going and going and going
and going until you get them it's so
beautiful to watch that because it's
like as if there's a pre-existing net or
grid of interrelated signs that will
work together and like as a white belt
I've got three stripes now I was Thanks
I was really hoping that by the time I
came back on here I would have a blue
belt and I could be closing
I'm trained I'm training three times a
week private and I'm attending two
classes and what I've done this is good
thanks a lot and was a significant step
for me is like now in the classes when
I'm spire of people I don't try just in
the handshake to manipulate them into
going easy
Ralph we go then please try to
manipulate people yeah like just a
subtle gesture or something you avoid
big people yeah sometimes like I try and
stay down that white belt into the room
but like now the more I do it like the
more they coax me up there great big
giant men like her like there's a guy a
goat like the swans a parrot like the
hard end of purple bone above they've
Paul Busby and like there's people like
their hands and their feet look
different to my hands and feet as
different than their hands and feet are
different from mine is mine are to my
daughters how am I supposed to do
anything with these people like hard
water like drowning in hard water the
way they move unfold around me what I
supposed to do my breathing goes but but
the thing is with other white belts is
that what I feel is like there is my ego
comes back in because there's I know I
should begin something the first time I
got choked out by another white belt I
felt like I went into a room I'd not
been in since I was 16 getting my kicked
in in bus stops you know and stuff but I
felt like I was quiet for 24 hours just
sitting and reflecting on oh [ __ ] this
is a combat sport this happens you're
gonna experience what I write so it
doesn't mean I'm a bad person you get
used to defeat but it's it's that
humbling is very good for you you know I
mean I don't know how many times I've
been tapped out in my life but it's
probably more than a thousand thousands
you know and that yeah and there you sit
there while I'll tell you about
jiu-jitsu and the other and the other
thing that's been good about it is like
when it is the other way like I remember
like a guy that was a big guy on top of
me and like I was he he was
in mount right I'm not like he weren't
actually applying a submission but
there's just the sheer discomfort of
having someone there their body their
sweat their hair their abdomen their
reproductive organs their digestive
system feces in their bowel but then he
went to move to get on by default hang
on a second there is a moment and I
managed to escape from that and like the
amount of energy that I release fine
feeling it's also very satisfying to
defend against something that someone
used to catch you with like say if
someone's are really good at taking your
back you know choked you a couple times
and then one time they take your back
but you defend and you get out you like
are cut out yeah there's an escape I can
make this I'm getting better I love
being in the cave that mint will spice
because what my technique was oh I'm not
good at that never bother trying I'm not
good at that kind of stuff never bother
trying so for me at this stage in my
life to go and do something that I'm not
good at this with other men that's
competitive that involves so much
vulnerability and failure and learning
I'm thinking well you've you're growing
you've got be growing so you're doing
stuff that you never would have done
before even turning up at a new place
like I'm doing here in LA and making
those new relationships and doing that
you know it's amazing for me another
thing I are into is the integrity of it
right but was Chris clear a black belt
under Hodder Gracie
right and you came a teacher like if he
gave me a blue belt that would look good
man he would be video dude I was Russell
Brand got blue polish [ __ ] muscle but no
he doesn't do it out of integrity and
respect for that you know it means more
to him yeah evidently then assume the
act of kindness you know so like what is
nice to belong to something that has
protected and valuable systems he did
say to me you keep going by the end of
the year Bluebell I think but like you
know it's not dished out like there is
nice to know that there's some kind of
order an area where celebrity
manipulation charm humor none of those
things all redundant or redundant no in
jujitsu it's very protected anyone that
gives out a bad
belt it's very bad for their integrity
it's the the the school would lose face
so badly in the community and you meet
someone who's a Hicks and Gracie brown
belt that [ __ ] a Hicks and
Gracie brown belt he's as legit as they
get they don't get any more legit like
if you got to that point of Hicks and
Gracie gives you a brown belt it's just
it's irrefutable and that's how it
should be and this a beautiful thing
about the art form is that it has this
self-correcting sort of aspect to it
that when you roll when you spar with
each other it your ability or lack of is
exposed and there's no other way around
it yeah that's good to not avoid that
yeah but you'll be better you know
you're you're a fit guy you're a healthy
guy if you just keep going and get off
that [ __ ] vegan diet and keep going I
watch the documentary called what the
hell have you seen it's like yeah it's
filled with a lot of propaganda
propaganda damn those guys again
like the Nazis I remember it's they used
a lot of discredited studies and there's
a lot of epidemiology studies that'll
connect things that what does that mean
like an epidemic always know we could
pull up what the actual pulled something
out of analogy but the way I would
describe it is they would do these
studies and essentially it would be they
would they would ask you what you eat on
a daily basis how often DEET mean how
and it's basically a survey and in in
that survey they would say well there's
a direct correlation between people that
eat meat and diabetes so let's pull up
the definition but the problem is what
is causing here a branch of Medicine
which deals with incidence distribution
and possible control of diseases and
other factors relating to health so when
they're when they're dealing with
incidents right they're dealing with how
often do you eat red meat how often do
you eat this how often you eat that and
then they find oh well there's more
instances of diabetes and people that
eat meat okay but is it people that eat
meat and vegetables or is it people that
eat meat and vegetables and diet coke
and and sugary sodas
and ice cream and french fries and how
are they eating their meat are they
eating cheeseburgers for some [ __ ]
fast-food place or they eating grass fed
steak are they eating grass fed steak
and vegetables and there's very little
evidence that shows there's anything
wrong with eating meat if you follow a
normal healthy what they would call a
primal diet yeah cut out all the grains
cut on all the sugar cut out all the
[ __ ]
eat vegetables and meat and there's
almost nothing I mean unless you have
some very unusual rare condition where
you're either allergic to meat or you
have some very strange digestive system
where you fight you have allergies to it
or you have real problems digesting in
or you have real problems with high
cholesterol foods which is very rare as
well most of what you're getting is
vegan prop again the people that want
other people to be convinced that the
way that they're living is the correct
way and that eating meat is physically
bad for you and it's causing all these
harms what's causing all the harm for
people physically is the modern American
diet and that's been pretty established
yes that's right and there are clear
ethical reasons to be vegan in that it
takes you out of the exploitation of
animals but at the community what health
I watched was like you know not be
vegetarian for years and this light and
I've gone back and forth to veganism
because I feel good Jesus Christ man
there's enough things in my life I'm not
doing without not being out I have an
egg without feeling good your house two
raised eggs if you get them from a good
farm the chickens are just hanging out a
lot of chickens in my garden are not
confident in these animals and the one
by one slowly my dogs eliminate in those
nine of them two coyotes just last month
maybe two months ago I said pretty heavy
was a heavy toll yeah well we had a fire
out here and the chicken coop burnt down
we got a smaller chicken coop and the
Coyotes figured out how to get into a
woman wearing home and who came home to
just feathers everywhere I was
disgusting they're brutal little
monsters coyotes yeah yeah you know
uncomfortable they're the reason why we
don't have rats everywhere - all right
so yeah that's the circle of life lion
king was right so like hey though the
thing that about that vegan documentary
mate is that it it tuned into my
pre-existing belief when it's
stuff like oh the Diabetes Association's
they are funded by these meat and dairy
organizations and these pharmaceutical
companies the cancer organization
similarly accepts donations from these
organizations and it made me wreck
existing an idea that I come to it with
is you know like that whole pyramid of
these are the things you should eat
bread milk just were the figs that it
was easy and cheap to produce and that
were profitable they used to think that
they really did used to think that bread
wooden and grains were the most
important do you think they felt that I
think they did I think they thought it
was it was filling and it provided
energy and I don't think they understood
well there's no talk of gluten
intolerance when we were young that
didn't exist and there was no
understanding of excess carbs and excess
carbs leads to excess body weight and it
makes makes you store fat and people
didn't think about it that way they
didn't understand there was the thing
about nutrition is in nutrition science
is a it's a body of knowledge that's
constantly added to yeah I'm in fact
perhaps most things are who knows what
misapprehensions and ignorant sweet oil
on the earth that will be revealed to us
do you do any I feel like I've heard you
talk about hormone stuff yeah yeah I do
hormone replacement what type of things
testosterone in human growth hormone you
have to give yourself a jab in there
yeah you get in the thigh thigh you
won't do the arse Apple pride mrs. Rogan
its eyes right there it's easy to grab
yeah but they also have taking hold like
so you're taking growth hormone you
noticed any negative side-effects or
instigate your blood monitored you know
when you when you're doing something
like that this isn't this is also if
you're a person that has addictive
problems addiction problems which I
don't necessarily have them as much with
substances what do I let them leave well
you saw with video games when you got
here the video game problem that I have
yeah you frantic you merge that at
darkroom you and your sweaty sweaty and
pie-eyed and baffled by the one -
martial arts I've been addicted to
playing pool I get
addicted to getting good at things I get
it very addicted to things if there's
something that I get obsessed with like
jiu-jitsu or whatever it is I get
obsessed and that's all I think about
all day long I just have I just you know
it's not healthy but with hormones you
want to make sure that you don't
overdose yourself you want to make sure
that you stay within a very narrow range
where you're you know you're you have
what are the healthy levels of a person
that's in there you know late 20s
that's really what you want you don't
want to have hyper human levels which
some people do do hyper human you're
gonna create an audio system you're
[ __ ] up your body man you're just
jolting yourself with all this extra
[ __ ] what you about to take this sweet
lady thyroid is that part of your system
yeah I have I take are more thyroid it's
actually made from pig sty roids do you
mean pigs fire roads now yeah hold on
wait how what's happened to the pig
they're long gone they're not so
straddling over lack of thyroid
teetering about all emasculated well
this is like so yeah I'm interested in
this hormone stuff I'm interested in
that but you know me I've got to be very
very cautious about Moodle or in yeah
stuff yeah but if you have the exercise
regimen that you're talking about I
don't think you have got to do what it
takes man yeah
bring me the pill shock that thyroid out
of it directly
you should eat eggs though man you
really should you should eat should eat
some animal protein without I mean if
you oppose the moral aspect of killing
an animal which I totally understand and
appreciate and that's what led me to
become a hunter in the first place is
that I was really uncomfortable watching
these animal rights videos of factory
farming I thought it was disgusting I
was like I don't want to participate in
this it's reprehend hunting is a
different thing man to me hunting is
this intense it's very spiritual in a
way I mean people don't get it because
they see you celebrating when it's over
because it's very very very difficult to
close in on a wild animal hunt in mostly
elk
well Elks my favorite for two reasons
one it's very delicious super nutritious
also if I shoot one elk I can eat it for
like eight months
what is freezing them so yeah freezing
them so you're out stalking an elk on
the plains where are you like near where
you live you just go ah how do you
follow and you know you do travel on
bikes if you whitetail hunt a lot of
times you would go into the woods with
bikes because they don't leave a scent
the way your feet do mm-hmm you know and
animals don't associate the sound of a
bike the way the associate with like the
sound of stepping bipedal hominids
having to evolve trail bipedal
yeah they see you on a bike they're
leaving freaked out as much delightful
never seen my brain what are these
things
yeah elk are they like herd animals herd
yeah yeah I see a herd of them and try
to figure out which way the winds
blowing and you try to get close to them
is this a video of us yeah this is a
beautiful place I can see the heart of
nature
now the fingers of me I see that elk
there and I sort of feel like a sort of
I've watched too much seasoning um you
know like I see that elk and I feel like
I'm Bambi literally you know like I
don't have E it later Lee in the morning
you look yeah tired not tired mine only
afternoon actually till those late
afternoon yeah like say like I from that
position try I would love the game of
being a because actually I've had to go
down gun ranges it turns out in pretty
good shot there's nice to see that thing
come back we've like holes around this
abdomen and it's a I think satisfied
there you've been dealt with paper man
but but like the elk
I couldn't I've got too much empathy in
me that I couldn't deal with the feeling
of after it was yeah sure I liked it
like almost thinking about it the
sentimentality of it I've
sentimentalized it now you know at least
I had don't eat me and stuff like that
so it's not like I have all those
feelings of but can handle it in a
packaged portioned off way yeah it's
just I feel too much like oh that
creature so what in your head when
you're doing it when you're pulling the
trigger you're not having what's going
on in your mind well you you only are
hunting these mature animals that have
already passed on their genes you also
are recognizing that if you're not
killing these things
it's not like they're gonna live forever
yeah they are they live a short life a
short life with a very violent death
it's either wolves or mountain lions or
bears or something's gonna take them out
yeah what you're doing is essentially
dipping your toe into the natural world
and I've heard the argument that well
this is ridiculous because everyone
can't do that you know if everyone went
out and hunted all the animals there
would be no animals left which is true
but I'm not everyone yes so I don't you
know I'm going to use that if everyone
did the argument it's a good argument
because you if you're encouraging people
to hunt it is kind of a good argument
because it's not realistic it's not
sustainable but the other thing to
recognize is that the reason why most of
this wildlife exists in the first place
a lot of it was wiped out in the early
20th century from what they call market
hunting in the late late 19th century
early 20th century they you know they
didn't have refrigeration and it was
hard to get food and we didn't have the
same sort of large-scale agriculture
that we have today
and so when someone would want meat they
would someone he would either have to
hunt it for you and you would go to the
market and and get that hunted food or
you would go out and do it yourself
and they basically wiped out most of the
wildlife in North America to the point
of extinction whitetail deer elk
they've been extirpated from the
majority of their range in North America
and only been replaced in a few other
places but the places with there been
replaced it's all through money that was
generated through hunting tags all
through billions and billions of dollars
there's a thing called the Robertson
pikmin I think that's what's called act
where 10% if you buy hunting gear and
equipment 10% of that money goes to
habitat restoration making sure that
rangers and forest people get funded so
that the Fish and Game Department gets
funded and all and also population
conservation making sure that the
populations are healthy repopulating
certain areas with elk and deer and this
has all been done through the money
that's generated through hunting yeah I
can see that there isn't looking at my
own feelings too
I can see that there's a potentially I'm
bringing a sentimentality to the idea of
animals that's like anthropomorphic yes
oh you can't kill that it what about its
babies you know it like I'm thinking
about things like that but what I you
know I live in a rural area in Britain
where like hunting is normal and I
wouldn't and agriculture is normal and I
wouldn't get very far if I was sort of
oh you can't chew those pheasants look
at their feathers they're beautiful you
know I mean like you wouldn't it's not a
help for watching so whilst I like
record like in myself I couldn't do that
because like I don't it messes me up on
a sort of a feels like a very deep
visceral level you know like but I feel
that this is precisely the kind of
territory where we have to look at
acknowledging and tolerate indifference
between us this is where I feel like the
sort of these ossified polarized
positions between right and left are
starting to take root because if someone
like me who don't eat meat don't eat
animal products and wouldn't hunt for
ethical reasons starts trying to impose
on other people now you shouldn't have
because of this that have you not
watched Bambi you know like that's gonna
mean that people aren't able to explore
who they are it's that and so my I've
let go of judging people around things
that I don't agree with because I reckon
I don't know everything you know I mean
I'm this this is like this is about my
morality is about how I behave and if
people said to me I'm thinking about
going hunting I go well these are my
feelings about it however though I just
heard that hunting does contribute
apparently the survival to some species
and there is an argument that it's quite
natural in indigenous and it's probably
a way of getting in contact with who we
are originally as hunting people is an
important part of our anthropological
history and possibly a lot of the
condemnation of hunting is part of the
rejection of who we used to be is we
become overly civilized and more and
more than hatched from what it is to be
human
whether that sacred or pragmatic we
don't know what human beings are anymore
we reject our own sexuality we reject
their own bodies we reject you know
we're trying to turn ourselves in these
sort of cyborgs these emotionless
sexless meaningless creatures where is
our passion where is our connection
the sacred they would go hold on only
after about hunting when are you gonna
stop talking never gave me I will pummel
you with my belief system on other
things yeah like so I don't feel like
that ain't we're getting the judging
people um but like I'm interested as
well with this I keep bringing up the
subject of DMT like what I guess what I
want to know about is like because I'm
you know obviously a person in recovery
I don't drink I don't take drugs haven't
done for a long time and I recognized
for certain people that they can't do it
safely psychedelics and hallucinogens it
seemed to me exist in a realm outside of
that because they're not about they're
not pleasure-seeking there's like seems
to me like it's a spiritual pool however
I'm a crafty bastard when it comes to
this stuff and I'm always looking for an
in you know when I see your cannabis
treasure-trove over there I mean that is
some yeah as you said the let Raiders of
the Lost Ark stuff and I'm holding in my
hand now the CBD rich cannabis soft gels
clasp in it you know so I'm worried that
that is a gateway that CBD which is not
necessarily psycho psycho back it's not
but it does help you with anxiety it
helps a lot of people because alleviates
a lot of inflammation which tends to
have a corresponding impact on on your
anxiety okay so this says here 11
milligrams of THC does that mean I mean
it says THC you just say that the bottom
the probably wonder one this is the
wonder one might be already 18 to 1 or
11 it says there's an 11 is a couple
different ones in that box I give you
almost like a smack don't take that this
one goes this one this one's way more
powerful everyone you seem do you seem
very relaxed and free from anxiety great
I will say that but like what I suppose
I'm interested in because I listen I'm
meditating the whole like I meditate a
lot I'm doing all these things I'm
experiencing transcendent States I'm
experiencing what it's like to not feel
attached to my identity as Russell who
are you before you are Russell who are
you before you identify yourself as a
man in England who are you who is the
person who is the consciousness who is
the awareness then when I listen to say
Terence Mckenna
talking about his experiences in psychic
such length and with such lucidity and
with so many philosophical connotations
and the way that he uses the information
he's getting from Hallucigenia
experiences to speculate on how we
should organize society what what the
implications are for freedom
he's refusal to accept that there are
certain kind of experiences that should
be prohibited that it's ridiculous that
adults should be prevented from having
that I I'm fascinated by I'm also I
suppose part of my biases I love
anything that gets me out of my head I
feel a tremendous sense of relief
whether it's through meditation or even
sport the or sex being relieved of the
burden of the constantly thinking mind
but when I hear like those vivid
descriptions of BMT realm or wesker I
think something in me hungers for that
hungers for it do you worry that you're
trying to get intoxicated you worry that
you're but you're trying to find a
loophole yeah because I am doing that
I'm I'm looking for a loophole I go
around trash lawyer looking for some way
yeah I mean I know people that have
problems with addiction that I've done
psychedelics and didn't have a problem
but I'm sure some people have had
problems and I don't know about them DMT
is interesting in that first of all it's
very quick the experience is only about
15 minutes 20 minutes max and it's also
it's not necessary it's not an
intoxicant in the way that you would
think about traditionally you are still
you in in the face of this experience
and I think I think it's some sort of a
chemical gateway and that's what I think
I think there's a gateway in your mind
that can lead to some other dimension
that's probably there all the time if
there is a omnipresent continually exist
in realm that human beings aren't
accessing because of that particular
biochemical formulation of consciousness
as it is in this point in our evolution
yeah and that we can get there and it
seems as like you know I've heard
Terence Mckenna say it's more real you
know it's more real there's stuff in
there you know and excuse me and when he
talks about them beings you know like
that he describes herself dribbling
basketballs creating
Faberge egg Lion of iDevice his fruit
vibration I didn't see it I never saw
one he's called the Machine Elms he's
called them all sorts of different
things the way I've described them is
they're the geometric patterns made out
of love and understanding they seem like
so you've read you can look at a
geometrical pattern and read meaning
into it had an emotional quality they're
made out of something and they move they
change like they don't stay what they
are they're constantly evolving in front
of you into something more and more
beautiful it's very weird what did it
make you feel like I knew nothing there
was the most profound aspect like all of
this stuff that you concentrate on every
day is nonsense
and there is some other thing that's
connected that's probably influencing
this world
yeah and it's probably what with people
see when they have near-death
experiences the depictions of the
afterlife I mean that's probably what it
all is and religious experience is when
prophets are talked about oh my god I
went into this realm there's these
beings I've told me we're all one we
have scholars scholars in Jerusalem are
connecting Moses's experience with the
burning bush to the acacia tree the
acacia tree which is rich in DMT the
burning bush is what God was to Moses
and that through this burning bush he
came out with these 10 commandments of
how people should live their lives I
mean that easily could have been just a
very convoluted sort of translation of a
DMT trip certainly and also when you
think of certainly there are archetypal
images that seem to be repeated through
our ancient cultures on an archaic
stories that seem to refer to the
potential for plant experiences to
affect consciousness even the Garden of
Eden do not eat of the fruit of the tree
of knowledge otherwise you will become
as gods
you know alike I sense that now if if
there is some realm that we can reach
through that experience but see that
puts into perspective everything that
else we experience on the material realm
and that thing seems to in your words be
emanate in love and understanding while
ever-changing completely formless and
communicate in love and understanding
for I can't help but think that that
should
become our priority to have a
relationship with that girl and to bring
about that experience I don't even mean
in a literal way because even Terence
Mckenna said there are some people vom
rubble souls he was probably referring
to people like me that probably
shouldn't mess around with that kind of
stuff really talking about people with
schizophrenia rather which he believed
he had by the way today yeah he he had
some very unique perspectives on
schizophrenia the the way people
interact with the world itself I think
if we lived in a healthy world a healthy
civilization that had a healthy
relationship with psychoactive
substances we'd probably have centres
where you would have a legitimate shaman
a medical adviser and someone would take
you through a guided experience we're
doing that now
with ketamine there's a lot of people
that are very depressed that are having
these physician controlled ketamine
experiences that have had a profound
effect on their depression my friend
Neil Brendan's gone through several of
them and he was he's a comedian a very
funny comedian so when he was describing
it was hilarious I'm going to a doctor's
office and tripping his [ __ ] balls
off you know and the doctors shooting
him up with intramuscular ketamine oh my
god yeah and he's having these insane
yeah I go see you're having psychedelic
experiences like oh ya mean tripping his
[ __ ] balls off in these whatever
states that ketamine I've never
experienced ketamine I don't know what
it does but it's apparently profoundly
hallucinogenic and you have wild crazy
experiences on it and for whatever
reason it has a great impact on
depression for a lot of people I think
it's a perspective enhancer but it also
does something to rewire the mind well
what some of this suggests is that
mental illness is a response to our
material conditions whether that mental
illness is schizophrenia depression or
addiction is like like people have gone
wrong hang on a minute listen how we're
supposed to live I took that came in one
time towards the end of my using and it
as usual it's not in the right type of
environment we doing stuff and a
nightclub you need to be under that
shamanic conditions why
or whatever whoever you know nominate is
a shame but I felt like it was like
going into a tunnel made of sound and I
having to navigate it I'm still in
reality we're gonna do it as myself
consciousness becomes a noise yeah
instead of a string of words and signs
you know I'm gonna get out of this place
you know so like for me it's clear that
drugs were never meant to be
recreational in fact they never worked
I was never hey man this is crazy I was
like I'm [ __ ] pain I need some [ __ ]
to help me out otherwise I'm gonna
probably kill myself yeah you know so
like it was a way of holding that stuff
at arm's length
so I guess my renewed curiosity around
DMT in Iowa and ayahuasca and other sort
of plant medicines and like you know
that do you know Daniel Pinchbeck and
like them guys that are sort of part of
that I'm curious about it because I
guess I'm continually trying to find a
way with someone go right here's a way
where we can do it where it's sort of
safe and I've heard of other people in
recovery doing it and when I think about
what my motivation is is when I hear
people talking about and my own and my
own recollections of experiencing what
felt like god and by God I mean a sense
of oneness and that my individual
identity isn't my real identity and I'm
connected to everything and love is the
most important thing you know III want a
real experience of that so that when I'm
out in the world I can remember when I'm
driving or when I'm dealing with people
or if I'm buying something or if I'm
feeling inferior or feeling superior
that like you said this is [ __ ] this
is like a secondary reality
don't let it govern you you know as
someone that's been seduced by fame a
person life if I get this pons film then
everyone's gonna love me oh if this
stand-up set goes well you know like a
person's placed all of my well-being
outside of myself the certain knowledge
that there is an inner connection that
will take care of you that's accessible
I guess I'm you know hungry to sort of
feel it in a way that's like oh my god
now there is no doubt so in a sense is a
crisis of faith no twice in psychedelic
states that you could achieve without
taking anything I mean you can certainly
get there in a floatation tank you could
get there through holotropic breathing
I've never done kundalini yoga but
apparently the people that get really
deep into Kundalini oh you can literally
have DMT trips yeah I have friends that
have done DMT and have experienced DMT
trips through Kundalini but you have to
be really dead
I mean there's a lot of time a lot of
time a lot of energy and you have to
really understand the methods and and
follow them to a tee and you can achieve
these altered states of consciousness
that are apparently you know not for my
personal experience but from people
telling me incredibly profound yeah I
mean I've had comparable things I guess
but what it's you know the difference
between feeling something that's that
overwhelming that gives you no choice
you know like this like it's not like in
a Kundalini you got do these breasts
correctly you got to sit there you go
try again have you done it yeah done
quite a bit really knee well what for me
feel like what I felt quite a lot yogic
Lee and meditatively is a cessation of
what I would call my individual
consciousness like oh I'm not this this
isn't Who I am this is just a temporary
experience and all of the value systems
of our world are built upon these primal
drives in collaboration with a culture
the like the stratified people and
manage people and operates like a
massive farm where it's easier to keep
people together operating in these kind
of way systemically I've sort of felt
rushes of that like a certain wordless
clarity if you can imagine me having
anything that was wordless even for a
moment and like and in that space you
know there was there is great pace so I
suppose get that what's turning me on
about the like the DMT and ayahuasca
thing is that the way it's narrative
iced that there you're gonna meet
characters and stuff like that and it's
and it's gonna be plain and beyond out
you know because I suppose what prophets
do you know like whether it you know
when a prophet returns from there
whether it's the burning bush or the
cave they come back and they say all
this stuff that you're taking seriously
is not real there's this other realm
start prioritizing it or you are gonna
live in Hell on earth you're gonna be
governed by your materialistic drives
your sexual drive and it's going to
imprison you and it turns out that
they're right and so like you know I
suppose what I'm after because I'm
partly you know on a superfood like I'm
one level influenced by what you're
doing and how you've created your own
like your create your own business and
your own success like this this
symbiosis of stand-up and the podcast
and like it's become like a sort of a
lifestyle brand in a sense Joe like you
know I'm sort of like yeah I don't I
don't want to be continually dragged in
and he's collected like working within
institution
it's like you know I I'm over here doing
a bloody I'm doing bullets and I'm
bloody glad to be over here doing
ballers and working with the rock and
I've got a funny story about that if you
want it but like you know like really
what interests me is like can I be and
that can I dedicate my life to
humorously communicate in spiritual
information and indeed starting to live
it so later and I suppose what that
would mean is you know I'm getting
better but I'm not a person who's
obsessed with porn or sex or drugs or
like you know to become it to become
what you actually are to recognize that
we're all different you're perfect
realization of you is going to involve
Huynh in and all of these things that
you've created through your gift and
that my perfect version of me is gonna
you know involve all of this and not
everyone needs to build sort of empires
or entertainment histories or whatever
but all of us are on some journey to
self-actualization and realization as
individual as our fingerprints and as
natural as a seed turning into a tree
and if we don't have a way of accessing
that no wonder with this ice right no
wonder we tie there's an opioid epidemic
no wonder people are bored and angry and
lonely well I think what you can do is
be yourself and what you can do is
express yourself and what you can do is
constantly seek to improve and grow and
you are doing those things so if you're
saying can I do these things can I be
comedic and spiritual and what you're
doing it right so it's don't you're
doing it you know it's all just a matter
of what whether or not you're satisfied
with your progress and where you are and
who you are and how you express yourself
so your pursuit for excellence when
you're saying I've got to get better at
BJJ or archery on in or whatever that
isn't coupled with a sort of sense
because you're not [ __ ] good enough
that's they don't see or dive cause
wonderment yeah I love it
Julie joy in it and there's enthusiasm I
mean in everything archery in particular
it's very you know there's that book Zen
in the art of archery which is it's an
interesting book it's you know I mean I
think there's some real great points to
it but that state of mind that you get
when you release an arrow and that arrow
perfectly finds its mark really is Zen
it's you it requires so much
concentration and focus and technique
that you really don't think about other
things beautiful it's cleansing and
waise its mind cleansing I find
jiu-jitsu to be very similar in that way
to that it's so all-encompassing it's so
there's so much on the line it's so
difficult to do that while it's
happening you're freeing your mind up I
mean I think of video games in the same
way all of these things all of those
things suggest a transmission between
the inner and outer world isn't it
you're looking at the bull's eye and
then oh my god I made this thing
Traverse
time and space or BJJ I've been shown
again and again how to execute his
triangle and I've just actually done it
against resistance
it's amazing to feel that it's amazing
to feel that your inner life can express
itself in the material world whatever
well wherever you're looking to explore
that and to test yourself and when you
test yourself and you have to figure
your way through something or change the
path because the path you are on was
unsuccessful when you're doing that it's
it's really good for the mind and for
the I hesitate to say the spirit because
I think that word spirituality is so
beaten down and abused you mean it
become commodified yeah it's like yeah
it's like when people call themselves a
healer you really really are all healing
each other but I think there's something
to doing difficult tasks that it makes
life easier I really believe that I
think it makes life more enjoyable I
think it makes the bright colors
brighter and it makes the the dull
colors even them even though the the bad
moments if you have real positive
experiences with difficult things that
you choose to do on your own I think it
mitigates most of the hassle of life yes
I agree with that that is again and I'm
not particular mote this book because
I'd like all right we've however things
do but the point of this mentorship is
the idea that someone will exhibit
qualities but you recognize you haven't
fully realized in yourself and that you
can sort of model them and realize them
because later they you have those
qualities Oh like Kevin hora we were
talking about how a boy I find his
positive it made me think so real it's
unbelievable on a practical level you
know the way he's building his stand up
that
[ __ ] diligent and the amantha when he
talked through his when he talked
through his work schedule you caught you
fetishize hard-working man I think I've
noticed about Dwayne Johnson and Kevin
Hart buddy like you like the idea of men
I'm up at those people asking - I'm in
the cryo chamber I don't do that though
I sleep in a lot of things that they
don't do okay but I also you know unlike
the rock at least I do stand-up and
Kevin does to end up - obviously I don't
know if he does it as much or as often
as I do because I do the clubs I have a
philosophy about what's required to
develop great stand-up that you have to
do a lot of sets you have to do a lot of
numbers a lot of different places
different environments and I found that
out the hard way through my best
performances and my less good
performances like what was missing and
what did I gain you like this yeah I
think he's a sort of an interesting
debate you know I don't know if it's in
stand-up world at large but it's
anything I've thought about a lot he's
like that as soon as I was able to have
an audience that would come and see me I
was like I'm out thank you God myself
through that [ __ ] again thanks Dan hope
feels the same way whether he's amazing
absolutely fantastic I completely agree
and like because I fought like because
what I feel like is that the comedy club
environment warps your material because
you've got a appeal to them and I think
you ain't the [ __ ] arbiters of truth
you've drunk and crazy - am i mother
[ __ ] so I get like I perform I'll
what I'll do it's like I'm what I'm
doing to say at the moment is I'll book
the UCB like her or like places 100 200
or go Largo or put on events and I'm
doing events while I'm in LA because I
think all these people come and they
love me and they bring me beads here's
some vegan cookies and you gotta come to
the college dorm and go on after Joey
Diaz
because I feel like I like a nurturing
environment because I've done those
[ __ ] clubs and like you know an even
Comedy Store and later night Comedy
Store in LA you know as well as London
and I thought oh Jesus thank God and
after so like I'm interested to you
that's part of that what I think some
people could reductively refer to is
machismo in you like that you go now I'm
going in now
oh you know what it is it's that guy
that mounted you and went for the armbar
and you escaped right it's worth it
because it was hard you're like you
realize if you if a child got on top of
you and went for an armbar and you
escaped you'd feel nothing so when
you're at Largo you're performing for
children child stand up it's like you're
dressing with 100-pound women who just
started yesterday it's not the
make-a-wish Foundation Russell then tell
us your stories thank you thank you
children the counter-arguments of nurses
that therefore I am in an environment
that is sympathetic and he is my
audience and I'm not biasing I what you
know the idea of it overcoming a greater
obstacle completely appreciate what
you're saying but say you believe in the
purity of stand up as being some real
expression of yourself as in the arrow
hitting the bull's eye I feel like I
have a vision of what I'm trying to
achieve and increasingly it's becoming
about I want my stand up I want to hang
on you know like as I've always done
stories where I feel embarrassed and
humiliated but I want to hang off it
ruminations on what I believe to be the
nature of truth and I want people to
come out of those things feeling loved
validated accepted and that they're good
enough and that they can explore
themselves you know that looks more of a
one-man show in a sense is though I
don't want to like sacrifice the laughs
you know I mean I love the loss the loss
WAIS where we're at you know you don't
have a sacrifice in a one-man show I
mean you can certainly do a one-man show
that would be really funny but say you
start going into yeah that's what I'm
doing and I'm trying to build things
like around 12 steps and trying to like
doing things that people have some
takeaway value from now like you know
like trying to develop that after Joey
Diaz in the store
there's gonna be some resistance you are
you aware of Hannah Gatsby and the
controversial because you think about I
haven't seen it ya know what mister say
I'm gonna see it but because what the
end of comedy and all that kind of thing
silly there's no end of comedy but she
what she's doing people like and there's
never you want sometimes it's funny I
mean maybe it's stand-up comedy block it
become a sort of quite aggressive
towards illness
yeah became like a TEDTalk almost oh yes
apparently I'm interested you know
that's you know yeah there's enough room
for everyone to exert to do whatever
they're doing but like see at the
beginning of my let's call it career
like I I used to not prepare at all I
was still drinking the using I go up
onstage I drop [ __ ] up I'd get into
confrontation when I say chops you up
I'd take up animals [ __ ] part animal
parts I've got from butchers like like a
skull we've all meat and stuff and sinew
on it chop it up for anyone's release
locusts get into confrontations of like
so yeah exactly the reaction you're
having is the reaction they were having
like I was the front row I had like
fights I've got scars on my body from
Bad stand-up gigs from a time where I go
to a confrontation like I was making a
point about pedophilia saying oh we're
all one cultural mind so when a
particular Peter file is transgressed
against a child were all responsible
[ __ ] well that's how I've still got the
scar on my leg that ham there Edinburgh
in Scotland people didn't take it well
what I was trying to do was like create
I didn't have the skills to chopped the
experience than you know so is so under
equipped but like what I was trying to
do was create environments that felt
yeah I'm much better at doing that now I
can create that kind of an uncertainty
in a room a kind of a sense of chaos and
what's happening and then bring it back
you know I hope so a humorous conclusion
where people feel safe and amused and
all of that kind of stuff now I think
it's you you cut like because I did cry
and do that in comedy clubs and yeah it
was conversation it's not what people
want so don't you think that by prepping
your stand-up in those environments that
it biases you towards a type of stand-up
comedy that is limited
no because you can do that other stuff
too you could always perform to your
crowd and you could always expand on
things to your crowd but
to really put it together without any
fluff without any nonsense without being
self-indulgent
with respecting the attention span of
the audience that may or may not even be
there to see you most likely is not if
you go to a comedy club and there's a
large you know if you go to the Comedy
Store any night of the week there's 15
plus people on the marquee or on the
list and the show starts at 8:00 p.m. or
9 p.m. depending on the night and it
goes to two o'clock in the morning and
you know you catch waves in there and
there's different types of comedy and in
that you're you're gonna deal with
sometimes tired audiences sometimes
enthusiastic people it's all different
it varies widely and I think that in
doing that you cut all the nonsense out
of your act and you you develop economy
of words you understand how to captivate
people's attention and keep them engaged
and to respect their time respect their
point of view respect that these people
have an attention span they want to be
engaged in in the best possible way that
you can do it and sometimes you develop
that through these really difficult sets
or you know or distracted people and
drunks and all that stuff you can
develop that those qualities you're
always gonna have your crowd and where
your crowd I mean if you have this this
vision of how you want to put things
together you can put that kind of thing
together at a comedy club you're doing
it in these 15 minute chunks you just
have to figure out a way to grab them
yeah and make them yes really interested
in what you have to say you're right
because there's a obviously in like the
Comedy Store between now as you just
described there's a contract we're here
not grania to see you we're it laughs
every 15 seconds and like you know
comics like you know like Robin Williams
or Chappelle's that you know the
all-time great they when they go in and
accept those conditions you know you've
seen stuff I'm sure like of Robin
Williams he's just like walking around
in the crowd in that very room do it's
like it's like he's doing the thing I'm
talking about
and he's doing it there you know that's
when you think yeah if you like I
suppose I do get at that you're
road-testing it to a huge durability to
an incredible degree if you can pull it
off it yeah well think about every time
you're saying something when you're you
have a subject say say if you want to do
you want to talk about the mentors that
you have in life there's it's an
open-ended approach you have no idea
what the correct way to say something is
you try it you have you write it out you
say this seems feasible let me try it
this way and oftentimes people never
correct it or they never they never
adjust it they never go back and improve
it they just say it in a certain way and
figure out how to do it when you're
doing it in front of a crowd you're
developing these things while also
feeling the way people are reacting to
them and feeling their attention span
and it makes you with proper reflection
and truly objective listening to your
material it makes you change and shift
and adjust things you know hopefully in
a positive way get in and the more you
do it the more you get a sense of maybe
this is clunky here and maybe I figure
out a better way to say it and I agree
but the counter-argument could be that
it could buy us you two a sort of a
lowest common denominator area say with
that bit the way you talked about the
Sun and you know it's you know it you
need it's trying to kill you it gives
you cancer you know like something like
uh what was the journey of that bit of
stand-up is it's not for me it's like oh
I think afore I try and make sure
there's a tag so I know where I'm going
when I'm out there and then it's a
comparable process to yours you try your
best to get rid of fluff or whatever so
can you recall like what it's like we
know a you night after night going in
with new bits of material packaged
within things that you're a little more
confident yeah and I put that bit on a
special I can do it better now I know a
better way to do it and that's part of
the problem with doing bits it's like
sometimes you release them on a special
you have a better version of it now but
my point of that was to perspective
enhancer to let people know that bit was
about like understand what's happening
here you are literally floating in
infinity and it's almost never discussed
you're hurling through forever there's a
fireball in the sky it's a million times
bigger than Earth if you stare at it
you'll go blind it's trying to give you
cancer and if it's not there you get sad
oh yeah you live in a dream like this is
madness your life is madness
beautiful yeah it is but I wanted a
there's something about that particular
way of express it
sure in short doses and short bursts if
you know if you stared it'll go blind
it's trying to give you cancer if it's
not there you get sad so in that short
bursts like bits you know like wow yeah
that is all those things are true like
yeah it's crazy
there really is a fireball floating in
the sky we're just used to it we live
because of a floating million times
bigger than the earth fireball and I
when you say if you could say something
like that and make someone laugh you can
actually change the way they look at
things you can actually affect at least
the way they look at things we just say
something
sometimes it's profound sometimes it
registers but if you could say something
and it forces someone to laugh even if
they disagree with you if they're
laughing like I didn't [ __ ] agree
with this but holy [ __ ] this is funny
you put that thought deep into someone's
head and you allow them to think about
your thought process and and how your
creative process and what you're doing
to sort of bring these things out yes I
like the way you just described the
architecture of that you've got to
basically have these are some facts
about the Sun irrefutable now here is
how that affects the way we look at the
world and exposes to us that we're just
ignorant
we're not awake to reality we can't hold
reality in our minds because it's too
vast to handle I'm like it and I agree
with you that you know what that wave
laughter comes access to kind of deeper
truths and I've heard some therapists in
fact say that like that laughter is to
shame what grief is to sadness that
laughter is helping to expel shame and
to process shame there's something very
important about people coming together
and laughing together and I like to
exist comedic Lee in a world where psy
starts from a deeply personal
perspective and admissions and
acknowledgments of humiliation and shame
and vulnerability and travels out to the
universe or and hopefully archetype
although you can sort of travel between
those points a comedian nothing we both
admire Bill Hicks why I think is
fascinating is because let you know like
if you've loved Bill Hicks for a long
while then you discover man
that guy works material a lot you know
like you go I watched this interview of
him on the Australian TV he's doing like
a bit that I've seen him do you know in
multiple incarnations but I have also
seen him do interviews ways
spontaneously talking about gigs
terrible gigs have gone badly and he is
hilarious but it's very interesting to
me and perhaps it's because of that
background and that practice of doing
clubs that Hicks is very much a comedian
that's know I'm drilling this [ __ ]
thing and I'm staying with it you know
he was a writer I mean he did ad lib but
he did he was capable of going on these
rants spontaneous rants but he was a
writer you know he wrote these things
out and he was aiming to have an impact
with his commentary I mean that was was
was he was doing it was not just trying
to make you laugh he was aiming to
enhance your perspective on whatever he
was talking about yeah and as a it was
seems very disciplined yes a
practitioner of it whereas like say a
Chappelle if it was like you've got an
hour well you know he's got a very
unique process Chapelle does and he can
turn over an hour like no one I've ever
seen before and I was talking to Donnell
wrongs about it recently who you know
was on the Chappelle show with them he's
like we both agreed like he's the best
ever at turning over a new hour he can
have a new what he could release a
Netflix special and then have a new hour
within a couple of weeks he doesn't he
makes sense
I don't I don't understand how he's
doing it it must just fly in he's just
he's in a great space you know he's in a
great mindset to do comedy you know if
you pay attention to how you know when
when people study like if you read
outliers and you read how people when
people study why people are great at
what they do and what makes them
exceptional there's always a variety of
factors and whatever the factors are
with Dave he's got this easygoing
personality this like very carefully
carefree way of looking at things he's
also gone through a lot of [ __ ] in
his career with you know the the
leavings the Chappelle show and you know
abandoning fifty million dollars in
going to Africa and really understanding
with it what his real motivation where
he was caught up in that world where
they were trying to change him and
commercialize his television show
he handled it as good as anybody that's
ever handled it yeah he handled fame and
temptation I think better than anyone
I've ever heard of
he just said [ __ ] you and he just went
away he went away and then didn't do
gigs for years people understand he
would show up and do stand-up places but
he wouldn't book anything so like he
wasn't getting paid he was just he did
stand-up Dave Chappelle did stand-up in
the park in Seattle he brought like a
little amplifier and a microphone set up
and just started doing stand-up and
people just gathered round hmm and he
did this just to sort of get him back in
touch with his roots because he used to
do a lot of street performing in New
York and I saw him do street performing
in Montreal we did a club and then we
came out of the club and Dave I think
Dave was like 18 or 19 just started
doing stand-up on the street and put his
hat out and people would put money in
his hat I mean he was constantly
sharpening that sword and he stopped
doing stand-up for a long time in terms
of like booking gigs and then after a
while I said [ __ ] I'm gonna come back
again and then he started doing these
gigantic gigs and then of course he did
his two recent Netflix specials were
amongst his best work ever and you know
and now he's working all the time he's
constantly popping into the Comedy Store
in the Comedy Cellar and all these
different clubs all across the country
and constantly doing stand-up
ya know social media does not not
involved in any of that stuff doesn't do
anything just just performs just does
this stuff yeah that's interesting when
he it's like I I feel that some people
have like found the essence and found
their path and live it you like it and
like that you know that the like they
were a yogi or a priest or something
that's right he's just got a devotional
this is Who I am I'm not doing anything
there's not that and it yeah that's
exhibited even in earlier stuff prior to
the cry that over you know what you
would do you know the crisis if the 50
million walk away thing like by then if
he was at 18 doing them clubs he was
hardened he's like you what that what
seems so loose onstage was something
that had been refined as a person who's
comfortable yeah he was always good he
was good when I first met him when he
was like 18 I think he was 18 I was 21
so was somewhere in there
maybe I was a little older maybe who's
maybe it's like how old's Dave 46 47
I think he's five years younger than me
is that correct
46 or 47 45 okay so he's more six years
six years younger than me so you know I
was probably 25 and he was probably 18
ish 25 26 18 17 but he was he was so
like calm and like he was very it was
you're attracted to listening to him it
was like like look at this guy like this
guy's ik so comfortable in his own skin
and so friendly and easygoing and
hilarious but who he was then and then
who he became is all the work that he
put in you know it's like he had this
base of this really you know this
curious young very wise person who saw
things that other people didn't see in
the world and then he just kept going
and just kept going and then of course
the Chappelle show which is in my
opinion the greatest sketch comedy show
of all time even though it was only two
seasons it's the best ever and then
after that I mean he's basically just
done stand-up and done it completely
outside of this system he's done up some
parts of movies and [ __ ] like that but
for the most part what he's doing is
just stand-up completely outside of the
Hollywood system completely free just
goes up you know just talk some [ __ ] has
a couple of drinks laughs and and and a
and it's incredibly compelling he's
found his groove you know and that's
it's a beautiful thing to watch as a
fellow stand-up comedy practitioner when
someone he treats Yves this mastery
level like we know we were talking about
with this Hicks and Gracey of stand-up
comedy level because that's where he's
at right now yeah I agree if you become
who you are yeah yeah he's become
himself and he doesn't have things that
are getting in the way of that you know
that's what's really interesting like
you don't see him he's like he's not on
social media he's not on anything
Twitter or Facebook he's not on any of
that [ __ ] he doesn't pay attention any
of it he's just just being a person just
being a person and doing stand-up you
know it's uh he doesn't have to which is
unique to you know he doesn't have to
promote
things they just sell out the end of
what an amazing example what an amazing
example mm-hmm I've got promote some
things so what do you go mentors I've
really learned some powerful lessons
there from the story of the apotheosis
of comedy that Dave Chappelle's achieved
here's these obligations
now I'm booked here to promote luminary
my podcast is gonna play a paywall on a
platform called luminary aiming to be
the Netflix of podcasts meaning like
that you know your model will I imagine
triumphs further so like from like this
week my podcast will be on luminary as
part of their premium content is an app
through which you'll get all podcast but
my podcast it's like you've got says
that launch now that's launch cousin
holidays yeah I know that was in the
process of being created are you happy
with that because it's not lost I don't
know you know you know you it like that
you're gonna leave listeners behind
because it's done behind a paywall but I
spoke to sort of less Sam Harris about
like what he Sam Harris actually told me
about it and he - yeah right right and I
spoke to like and what I recognized this
because like the advertising model works
here obviously in your case and I
thought well like there it was like a
good deal it was a good deal I mean I
can carry on doing podcast form two
three years that's what you know what
this you know it's and it's support in a
lot of other content and essentially not
yielding any creative control of people
just if people subscribe they get the
premium content my stuff how it was like
only at 5 bucks a month like that you
get like Trevor no I'll lean on mine how
many different partners I don't I think
like when they're premium content is
like 40 or 50 premium pot good like you
know pieces of content mm-hmm so for me
I thought like you know it felt like
otherwise podcast wouldn't be something
that I could continue to do forever
every set you know art because I do
films or TV shows or stand-up or
whatever so like a different like you
know it did for me it wasn't a viable
thing to pay for in order to pay for
people to run it to pay for guests to
even get to me and all of that good
stuff you know know what should you do
ads on your podcast live then I did
before but nowadays it's an ad-free
model like there's a benefit to that for
sure
you know a lot of people choose to go ad
free and then they use patreon or
something like that yeah they're
supported stuff Sam Harris was doing
that for a long time but then he they
had an issue with patreon about certain
censorship of certain individuals and
certain ideological perspectives where
they were you know leaning towards
left-wing things and you know being
being restrictive towards right-wing
things and then you know they policing
the way people behaved outside of
patreon and some people found that
objectionable so he left and some other
people left like Jordan Peterson laughed
and ah I've never entered into patreon
that's into those waters but I know bird
does it I think burr has like one a week
that he does doesn't really yeah he's
one of the best he's so like but like I
feel like yeah I feel like it's an all
right thing to do but even in like just
with using things like YouTube and
social media and you know like Spotify
iTunes whatever like you know as we have
seen there's a point where there is sort
of censorship is a possibility like as
you discussed on the Jacke like that run
of episodes may as I said to you by text
between the Jack Dorsey the reaction to
that your response to the reaction
through Alex Jones and all that simple I
thought that was a spate of podcast
that's like this is where this medium
can be the Alex Jones podcast I thought
was the godfather of podcasts we've seen
the crook it was put it out tomorrow he
just gave it to me so I yeah we have a
guy who's hilarious
his name's polytune and polytune makes
animated clips for us with podcasts and
he's fantastic
I couldn't he did one of the Alex Jones
Eddie Bravo incident
yeah well they were there no not what
he's asking them to show from here I
went the flat enough no this one it's so
ridiculous here we'll play it for you I
don't hear what's going on what's the
matter okay it was
an exception if it looks like I'm here
we go
the guy does the awesome artwork do else
we're gonna give to this next and I
respect you I want you guys to yell at
each other for three minutes while I go
pee I gotta pee too
okay we'll do in [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll go first
okay anyways you are someone that I
could talk to about the flat earth
conspiracy you don't believe in Flat
Earth but you can kind of understand
where I'm coming from what if I financed
a research ship and make a documentary I
can't go over three months I will pay
one of them with money can you race
we're gonna need a are you guys going to
the zoo or in orbit okay you raise the
money go pee go pee man
you're gonna find the edge of the world
film the drop off with my iPhone yes yes
go pee man go pee don't you have to go
we're gonna send someone else the
governor you really think there's people
out there campaigning for late term
abortions you
flame of course I believe that we went
into a long conversation we played hurt
it is so crazy that I always thought I
was so tough doesn't have to pee anymore
the point is isn't it
why are we debating one of the earth is
flat dude they're keeping they have
human-animal hybrids yeah yeah that's
good stuff that's what I mean I feel
like that is the pinnacle of where this
medium can take us yeah watching like
that's like he was in an extreme state
what about when he could go buy a be
comfortable Kubla boy you be comfortable
I never grease is like I listened to
that podcast like I go on runs I'd
listen to this [ __ ] hell man where
else are you gonna get this content
where is that guy well there's no one
would ever agree to it anywhere else
that's the thing you'd never get a group
of people whose jobs depended upon
keeping this show on the air whether the
producers are executives they would
never agree to that they'd be like you
can't have that crazy [ __ ] on you
can't have this on you can't have Eddie
Bravo on all the time you think Stump
world is flat stop this
you're travelling between such a diverse
and unusual ideas and sort of the thing
with Alex Jones as well is that he's
like he's got it demonstrates to a point
that there's veracity in what he's
saying some things yeah he's right about
a lot of things you know we was talking
about animal-human hybrids we started
pulling up these studies they actually
have done studies where they've tried to
create animal-human hybrids non-viable
Amaral animal human embryo
they're trying to grow human organs in
different animals and there's all sorts
of weird scientific [ __ ] though we're
doing imagine what they're doing in
China behind walls look at this China's
latest cloned monkey experiment is an
ethical mess
they used CRISPR to add to human genes
into monkey genes and there's like five
monkeys this happened back in January
and this is a [ __ ] horror movie this
is a heart this is how the horror movie
begins why did you think that once if
that's what's being written the truth is
darker yes for sure for sure they're
trying to create super soldiers someone
is trying to create some super soldier
some half champ half human super
intelligent murderous thing that's
powered by remote control that is not a
good objective no I don't see a good
outcome for this super intelligent
murderous remote-controlled giant being
what if you could send those super
intelligent murderous chimps to go kill
Isis now now we've got a reason to snow
getting out there now we need look we've
got a nice contract with this defense
contractor and they're gonna that's how
we lubricate the passage to the
murderous monkeys is Isis that's the
function of Isis in their cultural
conversation is to justify the monkey
soldiers you know what one scared me
more than anyone that I've ever read I
read about this thing that DARPA was
putting together so a robot called the
eater robot EA TR robot it's a robot
that fuels itself on biological matter
so it essentially could eat bodies so
you've got a murderous robot that eats
people the worst kind of things that
human beings could achieve it's like
people are sat around tryna yeah
come up with them well they're that you
know the date they're responsible for a
lot of really crazy innovation in terms
of like military stuff you know but
Boston Dynamics you know they're the
ones that make those crazy robots and
they work with DARPA and those are the
ones that make those robots that you
can't kick over all right you know I
mean that's what you need one of those
that eats people and you send them to
the battle for you kick it over no
that's the first thing we established is
you can't kick it over
I just think that's that's the big fear
is that future warfare will be our
robots versus their robots
you know if we're starting to bring
about the worst aspects that the worst
things that a human being can conceive
of this channel them through into
reality it does make you fear that the
apocalypse hero I thought it was bad
enough when in the malaise of my younger
days I like for a while imagine if there
was a cleaning service where the person
will come around and clean dressed
scantily they do that whatever devious
[ __ ] you can dream up someone's trying
to turn a buck off it and if they've
taken it to the extent of the non kick
over the robot fleshie in robots yeah a
new video today watch this this is so
scary
this is Boston Dynamics yeah there's
something very eerie about that type of
motion you know that the way the
movement of a snake is deeply coded to
be unpleasant when you see it they say
maybe think that move me think that
ain't good the truck is telling Wow oh
my god they're polar truck when it's
tiny little Tootsie's knows that they're
that strong they get a truck come on a
robot that's a giant ass truck I mean he
is also just a husky sled made out of
expensive robots and a truck they've
spent a lot of time and endeavor to go
backwards I guess kinda but to an Asian
Santa Claus they're showing how strong
these things are I don't like I don't
like their gait Joe that's an unpleasant
gait
yeah you should be on you should be
uncomfortable with it yeah that's how
I'm not easy at ease with that it's not
it's not animal there's no compassion in
it this is it's it's feeling las' but
that's what you got to worry about
episode of black mirror or the lady gets
chased down by the drones I've not seen
that why they're one-way they're bees no
there's a woman who's being haunted
she's being hunted by a robot and it's
terrifying because if it's remorseless
lack of humanity and empathy looks just
like that looks just like those things
those real Holly Brooker he's been to me
that man's could imagine that he's
amazing he's amazing that show is
fantastic
but these things look what we have to
worry about is once
artificial intelligence become sentient
and you can somehow or another attach it
to these objects that move and they they
run solar power or they have you know
nuclear fuel cells or some crazy [ __ ]
that allows them to exist for a long
period of time now you'd have to worry
about them contaminating environments if
your planet killing everybody in the
environment and also there's no means of
regulation is there because this because
this is the apex of human endeavor
they're in what what can govern that
what can regulate it and like you say
there'll be a Chinese equivalent for any
of this stuff there's nothing that's
above acai no is this a good idea should
we pull back what it is you just pulled
up a thing so they're making that now
you've got that one I just showed you
there good hundred different models of
it are going to be available starting
production this summer hmm doesn't say
how much they're going well but
available for people to buy well it's a
hundred different model says produce a
hundred models that probably means it'll
produce a hundred of them mm-hmm like a
hundred different companies are gonna
want them but I bet it's more than that
yeah and spending about how much they
cost it doesn't say how much it's gonna
cost they're gonna announce that later
but this showed like a robot arm coming
oh that looks so crappy look at that
thing imagine we have one of those
things in the room filming we should get
one no no way we come here it's got red
eyes it's like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you what
were the first ones to help be friendly
just listening to us like Alexa that's
how it begins isn't it yeah there's
something arachnoid 'nearly about that
it's almost like you know that see if
this tunes into the DMT component of
what we've been talking about it's
almost as if we've already experienced
this reality we've already been through
the version where those evil insectoid
robots take over so when we see on the
screen we all know we're doing that
thing we're doing that thing where we
create those things that bring about our
destruction and I believe it's because
we've become biased to commerce and a
particular type of progress but one
narrative has succeeded because we
necessarily have to throw off religion
but you know at the dawn of the secular
age because religion was becoming
systems of bias and systems of
oppression and whatever systems of
what I want to say elevating certain
types of power one supporting it at
least that's good hang on a minute this
religion and lot of it seems like
[ __ ] what we've done is we've
abandoned the sacred and I think if you
abandon the sacred meaning there is more
to life than what we can understand I
listen to the Brian Cox episode and I've
spoke to Brian Cox the British physicist
astrophysicist on my show as well and
when he talks about like he said that
you know we know that there's not some
additional component to a human being
because we can break down everything
that happens when you move an arm you
know whatever and I feel like we only
have limited instruments we only have
limited instruments there's certain
frequencies that we simply cannot read
what else is going on when people are
having these transcendent psychedelic
experiences we're accessing elements of
consciousness energies and frequencies
that we are not able to access while
we're in this state and everything we're
achieving and everything we're building
we're building on this platform and the
bias of this platform is towards pride
progress and materialism and I think the
result is fleshy in robots and those
evil monkey warrior soldiers we might
want to calm down talk about what is
we're trying to design yeah I don't know
if I agree with Brian on that particular
point that we think we know everything
about where consciousness emanates I
don't think that's necessary but I like
the fact that he thinks that way because
he's such a rigid hardliner for science
and yeah the guy works at CERN I mean
he's a brilliant brilliant man so of
course he thinks yeah I also don't think
he's ever had a DMT experience that's
right I wonder that yeah these some
people I think give him a quick dose you
know like because I as well I respect
Brian and it's further to my point
similar to the hunting argument I can
but you know I happen to believe in God
but like I when I talked to Brian Cox I
got to the point where I'm saying all
right even though I believe in God and
you are an atheist that oh he said I
don't call myself an atheist what I felt
like we both got to the point where we
said compassion kindness and love are
the most important things in this way
who cares so when I say there when you
say you believe in God do you believe in
the traditional god of Christianity do
you believe in God it's a concept you
have your own definition for it there I
believe that that state of oneness and
transcendence that you're talking about
when you threw your DMT experiences that
says you know love and kindness and love
and awareness
I believe that is the most real thing I
think that preceded all matter and I
think that we that we can interact with
it so I don't believe God in a sovereign
just a guy away that the whole world is
like an interactive by a biological
living breathing goddess I believe that
we I believe yes that and that we can
commune with it and I am furthermore the
relevance of it for me is that it it
suggests to me that we should be acting
kindly and lovingly and when we're
thinking about how do we organize our
systems that our awareness of that
energy accessible to all of us should be
paramount in our understanding of how we
organize so like what I think is like
that we should look at you know like
we've been through as human beings in so
many advents that agriculture technology
industry thinking that we were that the
you know the Sun went around there
thinking that the earth was flat with
all due respect to Eddie brother and we
and before each of these realizations in
each of these changes we always think
we're at the summit we never know what's
gonna be the thing that's going to
change my suspicion is that what's going
to change is that the way we relate to
consciousness and the way we see
ourselves as individuals that we start
having understanding that what the that
becomes a priority that thing you
described of like when I have come back
from DMT trips I recognize this is just
an illusion and it's not real I think
that will stuck like I believe that we
need to prioritize that and progressing
along that line what are the
implications of this not being the most
real frequency there is how do we
organize society on that basis how does
that affect how we relate to one another
what kind of how should we be governing
how does that affect justice that that
should be in the mix instead of how many
[ __ ] terrifying arachnoid weird gate
robot [ __ ] can we you know like
that's the way we're going the
progressive technological route because
it's created medicine because it saves
so many lives but it's given this
wonderful technology the spirit of
entrepreneurialship but all of that
energy it all gets pushed in one
direction you know it all goes that way
and I feel that we need to invite that
back the sacred and the divine need to
be back in the conversation well there's
certainly going to be pros and cons with
everything you know there's definitely
pros and
with the creation of Technology I think
of this I think of human beings as if
you go back to single-celled organisms
they have very little awareness of their
environment and then as it became
primitive bugs you know as things
evolved they developed more awareness
but even us in comparison to certain
animals certain aero animals have
heightened senses of smell and survival
instincts but they're also color blind
you know and they they don't see things
they see edge detection like that's one
of the things about deer they see
movement so like if you wear camouflage
and you know your your pattern is broken
up with a grid and then you stay put
they don't see you yeah they're just it
doesn't mean it doesn't register to them
they see movement so we have a far more
complex system of recognition than they
do in terms of like visually the way we
see things and I think that whatever
skills or whatever sense is that we've
evolved I don't think that's it I don't
think that we've reached the pinnacle of
it and I think that as beings become
more and more evolved
they'll probably gained more and more
senses and that could be directly
related to technology it's totally
possible that what's going on with
technologies that we're also developing
through external means a way for us to
see the world a way for us to view like
what they've done with the Large Hadron
Collider is like the best example of it
right what they do with the Hubble Space
Telescope and other telescopes you're
using technology to gain awareness and
to see more things and that this is the
good side of technologies that it's
allowing us to have a far greater
understanding of all the variables that
surround us that we might not be able to
detect with our senses yes that this is
a part of who we are and then I think
when you're talking about things like
psychedelic experiences that's probably
another realm of understanding that we
haven't really achieved yet because
we're we're still evolving as a species
as a thing what I think is interesting
is that the continual bias along that
technological path is towards profit you
know when we see those
the endpoint is always how do we make
how do we maximize profit there is no
like the influence of how do we do
what's right that's like a sort of a
purse like a sort of a general ethical
what I wanna say sort of code is not
being introduced there is no regulation
like you know ultimately you know
ultimately people will create the
warrior monkeys or the most profitable
machines people because the the
counter-argument isn't being made
no one is like what I'm saying no one's
making it there's just there's no union
of you know there's no clear opinion of
hang on a minute where could we be going
no there is no body or ideology that's
able to oppose the relentless march of
capitalism I'm not sort of like a
flat-out or capitalism is bad Here I am
promoting a book using an iPhone or you
know I mean I'm we're all swimming in it
but what I'm saying is that if we
acknowledge there are transcendent
realms there there is information day
and data that exists beyond what we're
able to receive of our senses how are we
going to incorporate that in the way we
organize because otherwise the sort of
the magnetism the pool the g-force of
what's most profitable what's going to
continue to suit the requirements of the
powerful that will always the bias will
always fall in that direction and it
seems like where that's heading is
certain kinds of ecological disaster
certain kinds of economic inequality
certain kinds of conflict you know and
like we're not one of the simple
experiments that I apply is you know if
we you know if we people say oh what's
wrong with the world world so [ __ ] all
this polarity I sometimes think well who
is benefiting from how it is now are
there is anyone benefiting are there any
groups institutions or individuals for
whom this current state is beneficial
and if the answer to that question is
yes then look at who those institutions
are and they are most likely to a degree
involved in establishing and maintaining
these systems and there are you know
institutions and individuals and
organizations that this works just fine
for but are they just capitalizing on it
or are they organizing it and there's a
normal part of the way human beings
operate with this constant desire for
innovation constant desire
for improvement we always want to push
further no no one's comfortable where
they are they will always want to be in
a better place and this is almost like
it's built into capitalism I agree that
this materialism which is built into
capitalism also is what fuels innovation
yeah because you want the newest iPhones
so they have to design it and build it
and make it all right and when new
things come out like this new robot that
apparently you're gonna hundred models
whatever that means what that is is this
is they're gonna sell it so there's like
it's fueling innovation someone else
will come along and compete with Boston
Dynamics and then there will be there
would be innovation wars if these
innovation wars weren't in place right
now our phones would look nothing like
the iPhone 10 it just wouldn't we like
to sx it would look like who knows what
would look like but there would be no no
incentive for them to compete against
all these samsung devices and huawei
devices and all that stuff is fueling
this innovation but it's all being
fueled by capitalism you're quite right
that the innovation is one of the
benefits of the maintaining this system
but it seems to me that we are excluding
other factors like that recur throughout
human cultures we all have an idea of
fairness of justice and yeah I don't
want some clunky weird sort of Eastern
Bloc phone made out of grey plastic but
like we have to I suppose examine as a
society and as individuals what is
important to us there where I think you
know we've talked touched several times
upon you know the fact that as an
individual you're more likely to bias
yourself towards negative information
online you know like we do have a degree
of individual power and individual
responsibility and I feel like if enough
people awaken to the possibility of
different narratives that the the
capitalist idea of innovation and
success and progress that all of these
words can be examined what do you mean
progress that assumes a teleology a
purpose a destination if all time is
happening at once if space is infinite
like you know that bit of yours of like
you know to try and fathom for a moment
the limitlessness that we're existing
within then all these things are
construct
this is a construct and it is good to
have technology but it's possible to
like at point times of crisis such as
what it feels like we're at now and
although that people have said well we
always feel that every generation thinks
that they're the one because they know
their own impending death is coming and
they narrative eyes that is something
social and global regardless there's
gotta be a time where we start to
introduce different ideas into our
systems it seems like there's room for
that now because we do live in a truly
global culture that there is the
possibility for monoliths to introduce
new innovation and there is nothing that
can oppose it or regulate it we're
starting to see this kind of breakdown
so I'm interested in how we can
individually prepare ourselves to
organize society differently to be over
to overcome pretty superficial
differences like are you go honey and I
don't go hunting we ain't gives a [ __ ]
they start talking about how we can
organize the size where people who go on
in or don't go on in can live peacefully
in different ways not entirely governed
by a small cabal you know and I'm sure
Platt power is more complex than that
that seemed to be hugely biasing the
direction of this so-called progress I
think you answered your own previous
questions when you're talking about
whether or not you can be spiritual and
funny and like what are you doing can
you carve that path out for yourself
that what you're doing there by
explaining that would influence people
would give people a perspective that
allows them to say yeah like why are we
doing this and what is the purpose of
this and if enough people hear those
words and have that perspective
introduced to them it'll change the way
they interact with the world and that
changes the world it really does and
that's one of the more powerful things
about discussions when someone like you
says something like that and it
resonates with people and they start
thinking like why am i living like this
like what if I only have if I really do
only have 50 years to live why am i
living these 50 years in some really
unproductive [ __ ] way that's not
satisfying at all because I just want a
bigger house like what is it do I want a
faster car don't want a expensive piece
of jewelry like what is what is the
purpose of this path that I'm on now
versus a path that I could be on and
what is the real conflict
that we all experience between each
other is it how much of it is due to a
lack of communication how much of his
due to a lack of real listening and
understanding one of things I've said
about like comments and podcasts and
stuff like that I think one of the
reasons why a lot of people get mad and
I've tried I think this through like why
some people some of the response is so
negative to things don't it seem
innocuous on the outside I think it's
because it's frustrating when you don't
have a say yeah like a suit you and I
are talking about something there's
probably some guy right now going well
just [ __ ] stop with all your
spiritual [ __ ] here's what you do
you wake up when your [ __ ] alarm
clock goes off you never hit snooze you
get out the door you put your hours in
eventually you get better you take care
of your family
yeah act like a [ __ ] man and there's
probably people like that that are
they're upset they feel like we're
pontificating too much and this is all
just you know just mental masturbation
you're right in ways it is but that's
part of how you dissolve these things
and think these things through I believe
they deserve their say yeah well and
that's one of the things that you know
if being a person that goes to sort of
12-step support groups is you recognize
that everyone's individual experience
that is valuable yes so it's not like
that and I've got over the idea that
that there's some external thing can be
imposed and like you know whilst there
like many people that are you know we
could say not using their 50 years to
maximum effect because they are you know
pursuing odd material goals there are
you know many many more people that
unknown introduced to the idea of
freedom because from the moment they're
born they're economically tyrannize you
told that you're only if you are not
economically valuable to this system you
are not valuable at all and that isn't
that's only an idea but you know if you
don't know you know if you can't become
a lawyer or you know a comedian or
whatever
[ __ ] you well so many of us are trapped
in the expectations and values of our
parents too
that's a real problem with people don't
let their children become an individual
you know they force their children to
follow their own rigid ideology shame
them when they don't I agree with that
but do you not imagine that a fair
degree of that stuff is unconscious do
you agree probably unconsciously
imposing things on our 100% but not
guilt and women if your kid comes to you
and say daddy no I know you wanted me to
be a doctor but [ __ ] I want to play
bongos I just want to be the best bongo
player of all time I bet you'd probably
like hey learn the [ __ ] bozos give me
a hug yeah go get those bongos get out
there come the best BAM bang Goa you can
there or even mediocre sure but there
are fathers out there be like the [ __ ]
you are you're gonna be a goddamn doctor
stop being a [ __ ] and you're gonna go
back to medical school and you're gonna
pick up your studies we want to get you
a tutor and you're gonna perform because
we're a Wilson this Wilson family's been
physicians since 1820 your grand time
immemorial the Wilsons have been
physicians he's made people bite down on
a leather strap before amnesia he sawed
off legs and he kept those people alive
you want to play bongos you little [ __ ]
yeah people get mad but my biases
towards my kid like like so fine like
when we was back in England like I was
aware of like grandparents or whatever
reacting spiders and stuff going our
spiders are scary and then [ __ ] teach
him that spiders are scary I don't want
her to think of things as scary tell it
like this spiders are cool they're all
right there's nothing you know but I say
and you're aware of a familial influence
like that they wanted the hair to be a
certain way they wanted to wear certain
things they wanted to hear like yeah
part of the veganism is like if you make
these kids vegan at least now I know
wherever they go there's gonna be so
many restrictions on their food I've not
made the kids vegan it's up to them you
know thank you
where's my gold stuff it's my ticker
tape parade and but like so but like you
know I don't know what you know we don't
know our own biases we don't know what
where we've been institutionalized
you know because how you know the very
nature of the unconscious is we are not
aware of it you know so I suppose in a
sense a continued open mindedness and a
willingness to change must be part of
any dialogue to go into these situations
you know I might not actually know what
that's why I'm not when I was 20
if you'da said about their hunting I'd
be like oh no man do I love Jesus
there's so many ways of seeing the world
there's so many ways of looking at
what's real and what's correct I'm you
know what I think with hunting hunting
is like many things and that there's no
real
clean answer there's no yes or no good
or bad because you could think there is
but then you find circumstances like
wild pigs or invasive species like I go
hunting on a place called the nine it's
um one of the small islands of Hawaii
mm-hmm there's somewhere in the
neighborhood of 3,000 people and 20,000
deer it is so overpopulated with deer
hmm and they have to kill them to kill
them every day they hire snipers they
hire people killing people are slamming
in with their cars I mean they're
[ __ ] everywhere and their access deer
they're not even from there they're from
someone brought them over from India to
give to King Kamehameha and like the
1800s they're they're animals actually
that evolved to get away from Tigers so
there's this insanely fast beautiful
deer that are everywhere they're forced
to kill well the good news is the people
that are low income people of the island
always have me there's there's meat
everywhere everyone can hunt it's really
easy to find them you can you could find
them and if you you know if you want you
can go kill them
yeah I've got no moral judgement about
that you know if there's rats in my
house what I'm not gonna put down poison
I'm gonna go up but that's a thing that
is allowed to get Larry
you should probably feel bad about
killing a rat right as a vegan I do feel
bad everything I'm hungry what about
yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't swap a
mosquito even way even that llama even
the Dalai Lama low I see him he went
like the first time a gentle brash the
second time a harder one third time
smack the Dalai Lama like you know you
Dalai Lama gives him free chances you
might be reincarnated as a bear can I go
for the play yeah sure sure go ahead man
it's almost three o'clock already you
believe it or not he said your character
is neat he's got these incredibly long
rants you know but he's so self-aware
and introspective he's they're always
analyzing himself trying to find if he's
doing right I get a kick of these
celebrity dudes doing jujitsu - I think
it's hilarious it's awesome it's cool
it's cool
here I'm talking about it you tell you
know the struggles with it I just saw
someone else said they just started it I
can't remember who it was someone famous
yeah I might not be relevant at all but
I'm trying to think
Demi Lovato is like a purple belt or
some [ __ ] she's been into it for a long
time
Russell who you know I've trained with
it Russell's a legit blue belt I rolled
with Russell and I was like wow Russell
really knows jujitsu he's actually doing
the right stuff here it's hard it's hard
for someone to go from a place of where
a guy like Russell Brand is handsome
beautiful famous man who has got some
strange plumber sitting on his face
yanking on his arm his description of it
is awesome about feces in this bowels
and yeah that veganism stuff's for the
birds though sorry vegan people to eat
eggs if you don't want to kill any
animals please just find find a good
farm that has pasture-raised eggs and
see how much better you feel or eat
animals they're [ __ ] should find
animals that are [ __ ] in the woods
only eat the [ __ ] somebody sent me
this horrible video that I've seen many
times before of a bear killing a deer in
a backyard and a deer screaming the
Bears tearing it apart I'm sure you've
seen that before right and he sent it to
me and he goes okay now I get it
like I didn't think I thought like if a
bear got a deer that it would be just oh
hey this is just how nature works like
no this is a horrific violent act of
this animal tearing this other animal
apart now would you prefer that than a
hunter because 99 times out of 100 when
a hunter kills an animal it's way
quicker there that's the video it's
horrible it's a horrible video this
animal I think it's actually a black
bear I think it's either a grizzly or a
color phase black bear but it takes a
long time to if you haven't seen the
video it's a long one and the animal
makes some horrible noises we're talking
about
returns talking about a video that I've
seen before about this bear that kills
this deer in this guy's yard the guy
films in the deers making these horrible
noises and this guy sent sent it to me
and he goes now I get it because I get
what the wild is actually all about
because you don't really see it that
much you don't really it's very rare
that you actually see an animal kill an
animal so we have these romantic Disney
find ideas of what the food chain looks
like out there yeah nature's brutal I
mean I don't try and impose on my dog
the kind of conditions that I would hold
myself to you should have an organic
garden if you really want to do it right
cuz if you're getting into large-scale
agriculture you're buying food from
people that grow it they're running over
[ __ ] rabbits and mice and killing
things with pesticides and there's no
there's no removing yourself from death
but just by eating vegetables it's just
you don't they have to reap also they
have to like when with large-scale
agriculture there that ground all those
animals get displaced yeah you know it
[ __ ] the whole ecosystem up whatever
area they're planting on and then when
they roll over it with those gigantic
combines and pull up that grain they're
chewing up everything that's why
vultures always circle where combines
are as soon as they have fresh cut the
vultures start showing up because they
know there's gonna be something that got
jacked see once you know that that
monoculture is unhealthy there are only
resistance to or in it having not
permaculture and the healthier better
agricultural models is Commerce and
profit that's not ok no no no your
communes which you could have as a
community gardens yes yes you could but
the only real but like if you start if
we start saying hey why don't we not
have monoculture anymore because it's
unfair and it's unreasonable they go we
can't because it's profitable to have it
and people won't be out forward food but
all of that is like it you know a city
an interrelated system that sort of
gridlocked into protecting itself yeah
you know like there's a spiritual maxim
wisdom is acting on knowledge and that
is not the world we live in we know
things and then we just ignore it you
know like as individuals or as or as you
know corporations and as groups and
like what I feel like I'm trying to do
is an individual ways hold myself to
that stand it's like I know that's not
good for me to do that anymore I'm not
gonna do that I'm gonna do like I'm
gonna watch myself and I'm gonna watch
that behavior and I'm gonna try and
improve you know like I don't want to go
like when my first impulse in heading
down today Ribeiro Jiu Jitsu plays I
feel nervous and I'm feel confident
doing it I don't want to go or whether
it's like giving up me or whatever but
I'm doing these things in a sense I
think these are the kind of improvements
I can make now like when you we almost
don't expect that of politic anymore you
don't expect us of a political figure to
say well listen monocultures I'm a
terrible impact they'll make some
gestural thing wouldn't let it go look
we're gonna try and control Facebook and
Google a little bit and we're gonna try
and reduce emissions this amount now let
go listen we know that's wrong we don't
do that anymore because there's too many
powerful interest that's why I was
susceptible to the vegan documentary you
know of course there's the ethical
reasons in my opinion for becoming vegan
but because it's like the reason that
these kind of foods are promote it is
because these powerful groups lobby
government and Lobby the group the
organizations that set the standards
until they shut up and comply you could
sort of say that about vegetable based
foods to power vegetables just corn just
growing that's the same that is the same
you know like you're saying that the
reason that is continuing is because
it's profitable and but but these ideas
aren't going to get explored because
we're on one path one teleological
journey like that sometimes what I feel
like when people talk about the frets of
different cultural influence eg Islam
for example right but I feel like what
we already live in a kind of
fundamentalism that's invisible to us
because it's all we know we live in a
culture that if something isn't
profitable it will not survive and I
don't think that's how human beings are
set up to exist I have this rather
lovely anecdote about like I was coming
back from a gig and it was a woman like
she her car broke down beside the road I
had a driver forgive me forgive me I'm
not poor anymore forgive me I had a
driver and we see this woman she's
better car beside the road of cars broke
down and different like it's a nighttime
and like a few different people stop and
help her the first guys like it is in
England it's like a Polish immigrant guy
comes and helps you know my drivers
Muslim geezer
he's helping I'm trying to help pretty
and efficient mayor say because you know
like if you're a famous person when you
go into a situation there's some times
you don't want to be recognized isn't
and it's quite a good to be recognized
when you're not recognized at all I
always think I'm not being all
recognized in this situation no one
recognized me in that time so I was just
there weird geezer at the side of the
road trying to help someone who had a
minor accident without any relevant
skills then someone stopped with
relevant skills he was like a paramedic
he took control of the situation he was
ordering people around you stand here
you do this go and get that go and get
my head torch he said at one point he
had a [ __ ] head torch this guy
seriously like he was like he
brilliantly resolved the situation and
you know adored her do you mean do you
mean like a light he had a head torch
yeah not a torch like a light I'm sorry
burn easy welding I just wanted to
clarify errs what's that why doing in
there that's necessary colour ever you
innit you can eat that you round off the
second syllable of colour you savage yes
with your color colour
we can't even say snooker we say snooker
we can't even pronounce a sport that we
don't burn him catfish catastrophe the
way you burn him burn
I know burning happen firming and
verbing Ham Birmingham listen this guy
had what you would evidently call a
headlight even that doesn't sound right
was headlamp a headlamp yeah like that's
an odd thing that's cool no no I have
one well your headlamp in your car yes
what do you anticipate in if you get
stuck somewhere man if anything happens
you should have a headlamp
this is the kind of person that you want
pulling over well listen when you go
hunting one of the things that happens
is you're in the woods and when that
happens when the Sun Goes Down you can't
see where the [ __ ] you're going you have
to have a headlamp how every hundred
very far I have a really good one oh
yeah I have a really good one lighting
stuff up isn't that gonna well your
don't hunt at night right it's illegal
once the Sun Goes Down there's no
hunting you have to be able to see what
you're shooting out I shoot a person see
some source it rolls lights on your
header just to help you navigate through
the woods and to spot predators because
of course if you're vulnerable you know
and you see giant eyes ahead that are 9
feet off the ground you're like oh [ __ ]
it's a bear it's a two-way street yeah
that happens I've had experiences where
I've ran into predators in the wild
particularly one time in Canada I ran
into a grizzly bear and looking in the
eyes and wasn't even a big one it was
like a 6-foot bear wasn't huge but it
looks right through you it looks right
through you and so when you run into an
animal that's killing [ __ ] every day and
it looks at here's I got demonic-looking
it's honest I've meat I've seen black
bears before you don't see that look of
a grizzly bear which is you know more
predatory they have a crazy look in
their eyes it's really interesting I
made eye contact with a couple of
predators a shark once in a shark cage
on like when I was doing that film Sarah
Marshall that done years ago yeah well
when in a shark cage and right and they
lower you down and you see a shape a
shark come toward you it's like it's
swimming through time it's like it's
come from another ear it looks at you
would like you think oh [ __ ] you know
and like and I was terrified in that
cage and like like Ed Norton was there
and with the Olson they were on that
island as well they were mates with
people that were on the movie they go in
the water outside of the cage bother
other [ __ ] mind
that's insane is near this shark was
little when apparently it's not kind of
shot easy but even the eye contact then
it's [ __ ] teeth I don't even look it
and then another thing I looked at once
I was in a tiger sanctuary in India and
I like I didn't like the vehicle I was
in there's a Jeep over there so I got
out of it to transition and my mate goes
you more getting a corner might just
[ __ ] Tiger over there and it was a
tiger like only 10 foot away
and maybe I'm exaggerating on a 20-foot
maximum like if it was near and the way
that that thing I mean it cuz it's so
beautiful
as well the intensity of being looked at
by that [ __ ] creature there's some
powerful [ __ ] you don't want iContact
without I don't want to look at
something that's got like that you can't
negotiate with you can't I feel look at
me even with the jiu-jitsu like I've got
that little moment where I go ray come
on we sell Russ yeah with a I go she
doesn't care about your mortgage yeah
neither does that grizzly bear doesn't
care they look through you kids yeah
they don't care it's just but that's all
it's doing all day long it's a killing
thing it's unbelievable cuz that's as
true as everything we are effect on it
just to ask please don't know what that
is so their idea of what the wild is is
really based on two things once they're
their actual love of animals they know
right it's like dogs and cats so the
animals that we know we as we we have
this connection with them so we think
that these are animals there's science
projects man those are not animals real
animals don't give a [ __ ] about you they
in either indifferent to you or they're
scared of you or they want to eat you
that's real animals the relationship
that you have with a dog is like a child
like my dog is more like a child to me
than he is like an animal I mean he's
like my little friend that doesn't get
to speak he doesn't talk but you know an
animal in the wild is a competing
organism they're competing amongst all
the various organisms in whatever
ecosystem they're in and either they're
at the top or they're somewhere below
that and that's just how it goes and
every deer is looking around cuz there's
cats and the cats are slowly sneaking up
on them every [ __ ] day of the week
and if you go in a place where there's
deer you best believe there's gonna be
mountain lions there because that's how
it operates and when you see that in the
water it's so rare it's so rare to be
around that but when you see that in the
wild then you get a deeper understanding
of what it means to be an animal yeah
what's horrific is factory farming
what's perverse and disgusting is the
way animals are treated when these lives
these livestock companies pump these
animals in these warehouses and make
them stand in their own
[ __ ] all day and then abuse them and the
horrific nature in which they're raised
yeah all that should be illegal
yeah gag laws those laws where
whistleblowers get arrested those should
be illegal those are immoral they're
letting people know what goes into your
food and those people are being punished
for that all that [ __ ] is grant they're
being punished because it hurts business
yes well it should [ __ ] hurt business
you're doing something that we all think
is immoral that's how I feel about it I
don't think there's anything wrong with
even if they if if there should be
standards and how cows are raised how
chickens are raised let them live like
actual cows that's beautiful and there's
a way that they can do that where people
like Chris Pratt
yeah from guardians got a great guy he
has he raised his sheep and he eats them
and he even gives them out to people he
has butchers that take care of it these
sheep are treated like like they're
loved they're not scared of people and
then literally they get walked into this
room they have no idea what's gonna
happen
a bolt gets put on the top of their head
bang and the lights go out now you could
say that should never happen and those
sheep should just live forever okay you
could I could understand that argument
or you could say boy if you're going to
eat meat and you're going to eat the
meat of an animal that you know how it
lived and there was no horrific moments
in its life it's just one day the lights
went out that seems like the best most
ethical way to do it maybe even perhaps
more ethical than hunting yes because
when I'm hunting an animal it's you know
it's out there in this this crazy state
where it's always looking to get eaten
these sheep have no idea they can be
eaten they think that everybody is their
buddy
and then one day they die yeah man I
agree with that you know yeah there's
it's difficult to bring ethics to that
that's clearly in my view a matter of
opinion some people think that's okay
but someone it'll say they get turned
around on me and say you could do that
same like thought experience with people
like why don't you just see people well
okay the person live a perfect life you
put a bolt in the top of their head and
bang shut the lights out and then they
turn it to barbecue
look yeah that's a very pronounced and
vivid way but I would say that in a
sense we're all like we're being
commodified imprisoned in clothes you
might like the very
fact that a law has been made to prevent
people regulate in or revealing the
truth around that revealing showing
shows where the true bias of this system
is in a way I think that one of the
cultural jobs this podcast has performed
and this is like whether deliberately or
not is it demonstrates that the old
political lines that we used to
comfortably abide with in a starting to
sort of break down because you know like
something like an obvious signifier of a
particular type of person ie I go
hunting now we have to accept is coupled
with your view that the agricultural
industry needs to be regulated and it's
disgusting now there are you know there
we have complete and total agreement and
we both can see that the way that
legislation is set up is biased towards
corporate interest commercial interests
and profit yeah and so for me bloody
weather you know Chris pet privately
owned sheep I think you know problem man
well that's not I don't need to spend my
time worried about that I'm a little bit
like Alex Jones like with the why we
worrying about flat earth they've got
them babies and all of that stuff it's
like why don't we focus on the things
that are making a genuine difference to
the way people are living lives yeah and
it seems to me that one of the
priorities is in a new global landscape
that we're living with what are the
dominant forces and what are the goals
of the dominant forces and how detached
those goals from the lives of what you
might say are ordinary people or the
majority of people to use it less in a
complex term and what's probably most
horrific about reforming the system is
that the people that are going to suffer
the most of the people that are the
poorest so if you think of like fast
food in particular right there's a lot
of like really poor people that rely on
fast food because it's very inexpensive
if you go and you can get a lot of
calories for a small amount of money
right but if you go from the fast food
restaurant and then you go down the line
to factory farming and then somehow no
they eliminate factory farming and they
say no no if you're gonna raise animals
you have to have the same sort of
standards that we would expect if we
knew you if we were there we want
pastures we want animals living in the
wild we were
you know fenced in but like living like
an actual animal not this crazy
warehouse [ __ ] you guys are running
well that's gonna up our operation cost
well then that's how it's gonna be so
then the beef becomes far more expensive
now the beef becomes far more expensive
than what a fast food what are the
restaurants do well they're gonna have
to make things more expensive - so who's
gonna suffer the poor people who's gonna
suffer with cheap meat in supermarkets
poor people that can't afford it no but
I think what happens Joe is you start to
put you have started to pull a thread
that reveals the how the fabric of our
culture is corrupted because it
shouldn't be more expensive the only
reason it's more expensive is because
everything is put into a capital based
ideology we're already I've heard many
times on the show you discuss in
universal basic income this is that the
beginning of looking at alternative
economic models and there's an argument
for saying everyone has the right to a
nutritious desire everyone has the right
to a safe home you know so like you know
if we start prioritizing those ideas
above these organizations have the right
to maximize profit on the sake then
maximizing profit that's getting taken
off the table and then there comes your
counter-argument about innovation well I
would say if innovation slows no problem
because we are we've decided as a
culture to prioritize housing and
nutrition for the majority of people now
you can say that starts - you know
that's that's kind of socialism but and
I don't think that that can work on us
on a continental scale I think you have
that we have to break down centralized
systems whether those are corporate
centralized systems or national I feel
that we the time is gone where there's
too much diversity like them not - they
probably always was diversity people are
different we were influenced by our
culture's our schools our education our
class our races all these factors and
then to expect us all to live in this
sort of single band width of this is
what America is all this is what France
is all this is what England is people
are too different now but what you know
if it does it seems like the standards
we were adhering to unconsciously or
otherwise is these groups have the right
to make as much money as they can and to
interfere with that is an American or an
British or whatever it was you know
beyond national ideas I'm sure so you
know for me that's the
you pull that Fredo it's the poor that
will suffer well then no we have to rule
out the poor suffer so we have so what
happens in the end you start to get into
redistribution of resources managing and
regulating the power of the most
powerful people and whenever that
conversation start it gets shut down
because we conserve even in a capitalist
system wouldn't it be more ethical if
everybody started from the same starting
block well that's what's wrong with the
world right what's wrong with the world
is some people are in a they have a
terrible hand of cards they've been
dealt
you know and my point about food is that
the people that are gonna sir they're
gonna suffer the most are the people
that rely on the cheap food yes you'll
soon as that cheap thing gets pulled
away then a lot of those supermarkets
and a lot of those fast food stores that
rely on that factory farm food you know
they're gonna be in a bad situation
things are gonna be much more expensive
and if things are much more if they make
animals live like what is that guy's
name Polyface farms Joel Salatin yeah
he's a fascinating cat I had him on my
podcast before he's sort of a farm
reformist and what he believes is that
these animals should live just like
animals when he has pigs he puts them in
a fenced area but he moves the fenced
area every day so like the pigs move to
a different spot and so they're just
constantly foraging and eating acorns
and but they're you know they're living
like a pig they're living in a naturally
they're not living in some crazy
warehouse yes it does same with his
chickens he has this mobile chicken coop
but he moves it from pasture to pasture
and this is how he operates his entire
farm
yes it seems again the point that's been
we've talked about earlier that we ought
to like if we look at no one knows
what's right so perhaps what we could
try and do is replicate what we do
naturally and so there is an argument
that naturally we do hunt there is an
argument that naturally we do eat meat
there is an absolutely Grob food to them
right it's an argument that it's always
saying like getting into organic
gardening if you have your own garden
man I mean that is like one of those
Karma free things ever if you can figure
out a way to have your own compost your
own garden
and you don't ever have to rely on
anybody else for your food well then
you're not participating in that [ __ ] at
all do you think that the spirit of
entrepreneurship could be turned to
designing these systems do you think the
only thing that incentivizes people is
maximum profit I I do too I think that
is possible that people would sit around
go how do we organize a society that's
fairer and just that doesn't kill
people's individualism or creativity or
right to pursue different goals or to be
who they are and believe who you know
but like I feel like there's so much fog
in the air people don't know what they
actually believe in because there's so
much powerful cultural influence so much
toxin physical toxin literal toxins and
toxicity cultural toxicity you know how
are how am I to protect my children from
cultural influences that tillens you
have to look this way be this way behave
that way these are the things that call
if you're not this you're not a man if
you're not this you're not a woman you
know like what like you know as a parent
I feel the obligation to create an
environment where they can grow up to be
who they are in inverted commas and then
when you sort of scaled it up to a
society you know how can we start to
recognize look is this time to look at
different systems for living and I what
I feel is people want to be involved in
their in the power systems that affect
them like if you have a group of a
hundred people they want a bit better to
run their own schools around their own
care systems from being charter their
own life not just be some little beam of
energy flicked about by cultural forces
that they can't reach or touch it's
alienate in and like one of the things
in Marxism and that you know very little
about this subject is he says that when
capitalism reaches a certain point
people will be lost
alienated they'll feel like a cog in a
machine no one will have no pride in
their work no will know what it's like
to make a whole bicycle and think look I
made that you're just you're the guy
that makes the pedals now back off home
you know now like you know like I've
listened to enough Jordan Peterson to
understand that there are limitations to
what socialism and Marxism can achieve
but just because you know capitalism is
better than feudalism that doesn't mean
that's the end of the conversation that
we shouldn't be looking for fairer
better more just ways of living well
yeah I don't know of capitalism as the
problems but maybe it's how people
engage with
capitalism maybe it's what people choose
to focus on if you're just about
acquiring wealth and money
some people are yeah they're gonna be
very deeply unhappy and it's gonna be
this weird game of acquiring influence
and power too you just have this
insurmountable mound of money that you
live on top of right I don't think
that's a good way for them either I
think if we're gonna really we're going
to look at this country fairly we have
to look at think of all the poor
neighborhoods and imagine being born in
those poor neighborhoods and imagine
being born in a place where there's no
resources there's no hell you're living
in the [ __ ] mountains of West
Virginia those coal mining communities
or people it's all just mobile homes and
pills and it's chaos and but just
extreme poverty what do you do if you're
stuck in that what have you if you're
born into that clan that's the group
you're born into you're [ __ ] man
you're [ __ ] we have to take our
resources and concentrate on parts of
America the same way we concentrate on
many other problem spots in the world
and look at them as like hey man there's
a spot where people are [ __ ] and we
should unfuck them we should figure out
a way to go into every single horrible
community in this country on this planet
ones that are just as bad as something
that you see in third-world countries
they exist right here in America fix
that don't ignore that that's crazy
though if they're in Detroit if they're
in wherever the [ __ ] they are whatever
whatever the horrible community is why
isn't there a concerted national effort
to eliminate that that's a major source
of crime it's a major source of people
feel like they got [ __ ] over in life
so they want to get at you and take from
you because you got that easy road hey
man you're born in the [ __ ] suburbs
hey man your mom and dad are still
together you know hey man your dad has a
job and your mom's at home baking it
[ __ ] you live like a [ __ ]
Norman Rockwell movie [ __ ] you man my
mom's on crack my mom's a prostitute my
life is hell my dad beats me I've been
sexually molested since I was a little
kid this is the reality that people
exist and they don't feel like anybody's
coming to help them we need to
concentrate on that the government if
the government really cares about us if
they're really involved in social
engineering and making America better
again
make those places better those are the
places you need to concentrate on not
tax breaks for [ __ ] super-rich
corporations that get you in place then
they make enough money man that's not
the problem the money is where where the
money goes what's it being allocated
towards the biggest problem in our
country is he's in impossible to escape
communities yes that so many people just
get sucked into this trap and for every
person that gets out and becomes a
basketball player or a successful
business person and they have this story
about the poverty that they grew up and
they they are so rare yes and then it's
not to be applauded that they got
through that it is but it's more to be
we should understand like hey I've got a
real [ __ ] problem that we're churning
out all these people that live with what
they start out in life with a massive
deficit start out in life emotionally
[ __ ] physically abused they start out
with everybody around them - loser
everybody's going to jail
everybody is constantly doing pills or
this or that they're it's all negative
and to do to ask them to develop their
own positive mindset uniquely in a
vacuum it's preposterous yes oh I'll
just pull them up by your bootstraps all
those [ __ ] hey you got to pull
yourself up by your bootstraps like they
don't even have boots man you don't
understand like you don't know what
you're talking about you've never seen
it you've never been involved in that
kind of poverty he's not fair it's not
fair it on if we care about people
that's we should [ __ ] care about yes
I couldn't agree more
no problem and it's everywhere in the
world all the Paul the crime and poverty
will imagine if everyone the lowest you
could live is like a middle class
existence boy everybody would all be a
lot more [ __ ] relaxed if you always
had meals you always had food you always
had a roof over your head everyone lives
middle-class holy [ __ ] I mean obviously
that's way past the expectations that we
have right now for the world because
like 34 thousand dollars a year globally
puts you in the world 1% you know I mean
that's the what make $34,000 a year
which is hard to live on man yes you
you're in the 1% of the world but that
standard that you very eloquently
described is I think achievable yeah
what be the aim and when you give just
one example of how legislate the bias
legislation is continually to support
the powerful while making the just
making nominal gestures to coffee we're
putting in yeah yeah and like so if
there is a point to nation if there is a
point to a flag and our belief and this
idea that there is an America and there
is a Britain and we're all together
we're all one and we've got a common
destiny in a common past then if we're
not if we're ignoring and neglect in
those communities then I say that is
what defines us you know and until there
are systems codes regulations that
prioritize that we will continue to live
in something heading to what if not a
dystopia something moving in the
direction of dystopia where their
priorities and dreams are sort of owned
really by the kind of bit mad evil
insect robot images that Wilson
discussed that people do get very
concerned when someone reaches a point
of excessive power and influence like a
Jeff Bezos type character when you see
some guy who's not he doesn't have a
million dollars like oh wow guys got a
million dollars like he must be so
relaxed that's so much money now he's
got a hundred and fifty billion and he
works every day maniacally and he's
constantly doing new projects and new
things and buying out Whole Foods and
that's like pinnacle capitalism it's one
of the things that scares people the
most when someone just acquires just
insane position of power and wealth like
like a Bill Gates type character who is
very altruistic very very generous Bill
Gates's accusers are one of the better
examples of someone who gains a lot of
money and then does a lot to help people
especially in his retirement all they do
is focus on charitable organizations and
yeah which is brilliant I mean a
marvelous and you know I'm not
criticizing the great achievement of
brilliant people but it like it really
for me that demonstrates the limit that
the limitations come from the type of
system as we live in that you can't
through charity affect every
impoverished community in America you
know like we the systems that we have
are oh well if you're poor like that you
know the bootstrap model well this guy
did it look at this great I overcame the
odds you know until like I feel like in
a sense charities become
kind of valve that allows you know
people like you and I who aren't poor to
feel like well I do a bit you know I'm
sort of involved I can wash my hands of
it when you know like what these unless
we there's no reason no America there is
no England unless we have integral
relationships with one another we
support one another if we really are on
a team when we see someone who's
completely downtrodden who's on our team
and we ignored them well that's not much
of a [ __ ] team is it no I mean that's
what I feel like when I come to red
lights and I see homeless people I feel
terrible
I'm like I feel like you know I mean
there's part of you is like don't give
them any money because they know they're
gonna just buy drugs you know let them
figure it out but then they're not gonna
figure it out they have mental health
issues and they're and they're
supposedly on the team they probably
born in America they probably have
national citizenship here you know they
this is our team and no one gives a [ __ ]
they're camped out under the bridge it's
like the the diffusion of responsibility
that comes with these massive numbers 20
million in LA 300 and plus whatever it
is now was like 320 in America yeah it's
unbelievable I think there's 90,000 in
there general California like a cities
worth of homeless people isn't it it's
not difficult for me to envisage that
when we talk about the transcendent
states that can be achieved through
meditation and psychedelics meaning that
beings like us can access them it's not
difficult to envisage human like a type
of creature a type of being a little
more evolved than us that would look
back and say oh my god they allowed
homelessness they allowed those
impoverished communities or why was it
oxide this belief in competitive systems
and survival of the fittest that were
resourced from ideas that weren't really
meant to be translated into that when
you were talking before about like the
natural world is fraught with
competition and Fred of course is that
he's animal so you know I'm not
disputing what you're saying there but
we can't transpose that into an economic
system survival of the fittest if you
ain't got enough hustle and muscle [ __ ]
you you're you're down by the wayside
you know here we have an obligation to
aspire to the better parts of our nature
not to continually use materialism and
rationalism to justify that 20% of the
population you know whatever vicinity is
a just garbage are just waste and
they're that's affordable we can a court
we can live with that is it for me it's
that why would we one
we have the knowledge that oh yeah we
shouldn't be farming in that way oh we
shouldn't have social systems all of the
answers always the same because if you
were to change in that area it will
affect the interest of the powerful it
will affect impede the ability of
certain organizations to make profit
now I'm near I'm not talking about here
I don't know the lexicon enough around
socialism and capitalism and Marxism
various forms of social organization I'm
just talking about my assumption that
we're all resourced from the same basic
material and phenomena we all have
compassion and love in us and if we on
an individual level can achieve some
level of access to that then we can
start to organize ourselves on that
basis not on the basis of well what's
the most I can get an individual it's
rational for me to I'm not involved in
that that doesn't affect me personally
you know and I think it's a hard thing
for us to hold I think the reason we all
do just live with homelessness and the
only decision we make is do we put a
couple of dollars out the window with
the light or not then like it's hard to
hold that it's hard there's a lot more
than 100 people there's no fix like
there's no that's an individual but not
as not one person and even collectively
as a group when you have mental health
issues unless you want to
institutionalize those people yeah but
then who here's the thing right if
everyone has a unique and if everyone
has their own ideas about what to do
with their life and everyone has freedom
what if you just don't have enough
people that are interested in in mental
health of the homeless people you just
don't have enough there's no resources
guarantee results yeah that's a big
question because our systems are biased
in a particular directions money whether
they have government funding do you
think that they could cure homelessness
one of the advantages I've got of being
a drug addict is it means I have to help
up a drug addicts as part of my own
recovery this puts me into areas
institutions groups facilities where I'm
meeting drug addicts and always what
you'll find the people that were there
is always someone like a man or woman
most often in my personal experience is
a woman some matriarchal woman full of
mother energy that just will do this
[ __ ] forever for free for nothing that
just loves it let's just put herself
like my grandmother did or my mother did
or like these women do between people
and the gutter they're just wind say
I'll be the person I'll be the person in
LA at friendly house it was a woman
called Peggy Albrecht it used to run a
play a friendly house was over for women
that have got dry
and addiction and abuse issues and like
this woman she was from Chicago she was
90 years old by the time like I met him
so rude and brilliant and beautiful and
entirely willing to dedicate herself and
I think every community everywhere
everyone knows people like that and I
feel like the same way as like if it is
someone that has got a great capacity to
play basketball or be a comic like I
think that when you spot those people
that you encourage them talented people
yeah the talent of compassion and you
know but we don't value that unless it's
like unless it could be turned to a
profit [ __ ] off all of those
organizations like those organizations
that help people with addiction issues
you know they are maligned and like the
people that profit from the opioid
crisis they are supported they are able
to conceal as john oliver brilliantly
revealed or they're able to conceal
their practices continually the the
invisible bias is in the direction of
profit and like the failure of certain
types of socialism doesn't mean that's
the end of the argument i think we have
an obligation to look for ways of
accessing our own higher nature bare
nature kinder nature call it what you
will and seeing how we can organize that
as an individual you can do so much even
if Bill Gates can you know [ __ ] no ID
no cure malaria and make the significant
charitable day no these impressive
powerful people can't make a meaningful
difference then clearly this is a
systemic problem well there's also the
problem with homeless people and that
they're adults when you become an adult
and you develop from the time your child
it's probably very likely that the
damage was all done while they were
young they're probably abused and
neglected and there's a lot of issues
that led them to either have mental
health problems or they had mental
health problems already maybe they have
genetic problems then on top of that
there's drug abuse to you for each one
of those people to get well you're gonna
need a massive amount of folks you're
not gonna have one old lady who's rude
people who would be the woman I would
like the one that was out of golden
curls Estelle Getty she's been available
Oh God Betty wait still hanging in there
yeah well would you book a movie around
her stay
how are we gonna fund this yeah it's um
there's limitations to the individual
but there's not like crash this optimism
in the crib now Joe because I'm joshing
the optimism but I'm saying the
logistics of it would almost be
insurmountable and it's very is not an
objective thing it's this thing that's
been biased over time sort of once a
person is developed once there are a
human it's very difficult to turn that
train around yeah if we can save the
community and save the future like help
like less people get through [ __ ] help
let help more people get through with
hope and with a real possibility for
improving their life versus have this
sense of hopelessness that many are
confronted with that's gonna make less
crying I agree that's like that's just
if someone looked at it from a social
engineering standpoint it almost seems
like they will the only way that would
ever have to happen would be there's be
some [ __ ] catastrophe that forced
people to act we sometimes need
something that's shoved in our face to
force us to act but if someone
brilliantly calculated the amount of
resources that it would require and then
also brilliantly calculate how much less
crime we would have how much less how
many more innovations because people
didn't waste their lives in fact they
got through life and used one of the
most valuable resources we have which is
the human imagination and creativity and
ingenuity like and we're missing that on
these people that are growing up in
these horrible environments where they
can't escape they're so [ __ ] from
they're in gangs they're you know the
crime and poverty and violence they're
so [ __ ] that whatever genius they have
is wasted on this nonsensical existence
if they could just show that and
quantify how much that would be how
valuable that would be to the overall
culture and community of the cause of
the continent and ultimately of the
earth mean that you would have a reason
to engineer and think about this yeah
it's a beautiful that is really
beautiful and it's interesting that the
way that I agree with you that it's
almost has to at some point be
translated into monetary value because
otherwise people don't seem to read it
yeah and safety for everybody for them
who live in these horrible communities
wouldn't be great again if everybody
lived like a middle-class person the
idea that that's impossible seems so
insane
it's almost seems like well then nobody
should live like that then like either
everybody should be able to live like
that or nobody should be like that was
like that's what everybody really wants
right you want to be comfortable like in
terms of like your ability to exist and
then all the things you're doing that
you struggle with should be a good
percentage of them other than emotional
and friendship type things should be of
your own choosing you choose to take a
difficult path you should choose to take
an adventure you choose to try to enrich
yourself with this difficult experience
and the challenge of it and try to
overcome that challenge instead of you
your challenge is not to get killed by a
gang you know your challenge does not
get [ __ ] by your uncle again you know
what I mean I mean this is what people
have to deal with and you're you're
missing these brilliant minds they don't
get this chance to come through and and
sneak through that [ __ ] Salmon Ladder
you know get up to the top this is very
beautiful that you're passionate about
this and I think popularizing these
ideas is important because I feel that
then people will be familiar with this
kind of language and will recognize that
when there is political discourse how
fatik and empty is that people will say
you know like I think in the last
election in your country it was clear
that there was no one no one is saying
that no one no one is standing on a
political platform of do you know what
everyone should basically be I live a
middle-class lifestyle there's no reason
there's enough resources we can do this
we could organize society on that basis
because that's considered outlandish and
you're crazy
and we're so there's so much I can again
you know with your imaginary Lissa the
listener that would consider this
pontification you know there's so much
anger I can I feel that a lot of
political events that have occurred in
the last five years or the manifestation
of a social rage of people that are
pissed off with not being heard and a
pissed off with a cultural conversation
that didn't include them
and that they feel angry like I want to
help other people [ __ ] knows but you
know that if that resource is becoming
so nurtured and grown and I feel people
would feel tremendous relief to let go
of that just to feel like listen it's
alright for you to be you could we be a
little more aspirational and a little
and consider what our goals are consider
what progress looks like to us is
progress the terrifying robots or is
progress
considering elevate in the lowest among
us to raise the standards people could
just understand that this this is not
forever you don't there is no such
things forever this is a temporary thing
you've got to try to eat as much good
out of this as you can and to go against
my point you know there's a real problem
with people being lazy people are lazy
there's not an equality of effort the
idea of equality of outcome like people
want you know income equality well
there's no effort equality that's just
the fact there's people out there that
are just they work harder they're
smarter they're more focused they're
less distracted they're more dedicated
they have a better plan they've got it
through better and they become more
successful and the idea that they become
more successful than you because somehow
or another there's some nefarious
actions afoot well that that negates
another possibility which is you're a
lazy [ __ ] that's a possibility yes and
what do we do about those people I tell
you this I've got a plan for the lazy
lazy Island Pinocchio's donkey laugh no
arcade games though they're too lazy I
feel like I'm well I consider this that
people that don't have a lot of life
force like yeah I feel that it's a gift
to be a person that's got a lot of Drive
to be a person that's like I'm [ __ ]
going to achieve this [ __ ] you know like
that some people are a little lethargic
and don't have a lot of energy I feel
that's a kind of despondency we could
break that down in a thousand different
ways is it poor diet is it poor role
models is it poor social conditioning
who are these lazy people weak genius
could be weak Jews even weak genes okay
then we'd like in the territory of
disability so however you look at it I
think you end up at a point of
compassion I think if you say I think we
should start at the point of compassion
because now they're all like what is
tolerance if it isn't the tolerance of
people that we
sort of can't understand as long as they
carry their own weight we usually don't
have a problem with it but when they're
so lazy they just Juke the system and
screw people over and figure their way
to scam through life yeah but I think
those people don't exist only at the
bottom of the social ladder
I think they exist at the top and the
effect there is were so he's all about
the president in those two this is my
country [ __ ] you better be found
him to be delightful you know so very so
sweet again like I say I don't judge me
there wasn't I interviewed him about
five years ago I was doing salsa for he
was the pretty was okay let me near him
on the wall like like he um yeah he was
sort of sweep I remember thinking why I
felt was why you don't have no
intellectual curiosity that's what I
felt well that's why I felt I felt like
I was sort of like him he was nice and
his staff at that big Tower they all
loved him but maybe just curiosity and I
don't think he's been very genuine with
that great make America great again for
you I don't ladies where's that everyone
shall be middle class we're gonna start
reorganizing Society reaching out into
Detroit and in a crushed mining towns in
West Virginia where's that other than
wise you ain't making America great
again that's true that's true
but think about how we were talking
about Dave Chappelle but one of the
reasons why he's so great other than the
fact that he's smart mmm just talented
and all these good things is that he
knows what he does and he does it
that's his wheelhouse he stays in there
trumps wheelhouse is making giant gold
buildings with his name on him and
spray-tan he knows what the [ __ ] to do
and he knows how to make money and he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about all that other
stuff cuz that other stuff is wasted
energy for him his energy is in focusing
on how you get more buildings with those
giant gold Trump letters on it no one
can argue that it's been a tremendous
success lately one of those hotels the
water bottle had his face on it you know
mean he's amazing
incredible achievement drinking if you
be inside of his face but that's his
thing right it's like why is it okay for
your thing to be tennis and that's all
you know about I don't even pay
attention to the politics why is that
okay but when we see a guy like him we
have a problem with it because he's
his intellectual curiosity is only about
money so it's even grosser I agree
listen the show are to return to my
point I wouldn't waste time judging
anyone as an individual because I
imagine if I were to spend time
examining Donald Trump's past his
relationship with his father the
conditions he grew up in what we felt we
had to do to be a good person
I would imagine our Cokie of course but
what I would query is the system that
elevates the people like that and I you
know the incredible power like and you
know again I believe in it systems that
need to change no individuals I think
we've overly fetishized politics I don't
live in this country so I don't know if
it's much worse under Trump I've heard
some things that sound really bad or
then it was under Barack Obama but what
my general belief is you have indeed
don't fetishize individuals and get
distracted to think about changing the
system because you were not getting that
middle class lifestyle for everyone
naive no one's offering that Bernie
Sanders isn't offering that no one's
offering about and unless someone's
offering that what's the where while
should we get involved have you ever
talked to economists about like what is
the problem what's the feel like people
that are you know more socialistic
minded they'd be more socialist minded I
guess but but understanding of
capitalism to the point where they could
point out the flaws in allowing this
infinite growth model where someone gets
to a point like a Jeff Bezos or
something like that what would they do
to mitigate that you're not gonna put a
cap like let's when people say that like
you're gonna pay 70% in taxes over ten
million dollars I was like one of the
ones that was banded about people just
start laughing like you're out of your
[ __ ] mind no one's gonna do that
they'll get to ten million dollars and
then they'll stop yeah it's stupid it's
that's I think a very limit in system
and I feel that the problems are broader
than that I think that they're like did
you ever sit like that you know if you
ever watch Steve Bannen talk that either
man like you know someone I would again
not politically agree with for what it's
worth but when he's description of what
happened in that economic crash of 2000
and I and the decisions that were made
further you know American taxpayer to
bail out the life financial industry and
I've subsequently seen a documentary
that said look this is why we had to do
that these were the options but for me
that is a demonstration of capitalism's
inherent failings and
but we're not talking about a system
that is flawless and perfect it's pretty
[ __ ] flawed aside from the human
collateral damage and that you have
again described that the communities
they're impoverished and without hope
and living in poverty in a kind of
slavery you know even in itself doesn't
work according to its own rules as they
are officially sustained and reboot it
when it inevitably fails just hold the
pure sign of it is that the fact that no
one went to jail for the subprime
mortgage crisis yeah those guys didn't
go to jail all those guys that with the
real financial I know so we're looking
at from a distance they were going I see
where this is going like this is gonna
blow up and a lot of people gonna lose
their houses like you guys are [ __ ]
like yeah then there was a lot of people
that engaged in those predatory loans
and they didn't get punished those those
guys the craziest thing is a lot of them
got bonuses yes that's right they got
bonuses even if the bank got bailed out
and they said the bonuses were part of
their contracts and if they didn't honor
their contracts they'd have a hard time
hiring these people and there would be
chaos and they've just made it a reason
why they had to give them millions of
dollars in bonuses yeah when they failed
let me get a bonus and you've failed
like your bank failed and you still get
a bonus like you knew about those
predatory loans you knew about those you
do about the subprime mortgage [ __ ]
that was going down in your business
yeah you just let it ride and now you're
gonna get a you're gonna get a bonus
what's the bonus for yeah what would you
have to do to be fine if that's yeah
that's the bonus you'd be jailed yeah I
mean just think about what they're doing
a Julian Assange right they're throwing
that guy in a jail somewhere that can
look good that embassy moves no but I
mean the fact that what he did was
release information that everybody found
very interesting and what they did is
crash the whole [ __ ] economy right he
was able to write that embassy idea for
as long as because it's not actually in
another country is it I went to visit
him in there as a matter of fact just
briefly popped in so anything's gonna
happen with him I think he's gonna end
up serving a pretty lumpy prison
sentence somewhere is in April I think
they're gonna get him on like what are
they gonna charge him on they're
charging on like hacking charges or some
[ __ ] now which they didn't charge him on
before right is that what's emerged and
he's going to be extradited
this country is that true I don't know
well I mean again I suppose this is what
happens if you challenge the interest of
the powerful if Trump was really if
Trump really want to get people on the
side he pardoned them do you think that
that would be popular because like
someone like that Edward Snowden is it
like look I'm yeah obviously I think
don't put the lives of people at risk
that are in compromised military
positions that seems like a fairly
obvious thing but like I don't think
they did that but nice what I understood
was they got hacked and someone else
released the documents without the names
redacted yeah it seems to me where he
leaks never did that it would it Snowden
it seems to qualify for a hero in pretty
much any way you look at it into a
twenty six-year-old person making that
decision and yeah very brilliant you
know I've heard him I think he was on
neil degrasse tyson's podcast they
talked to him Wow but did you see in
citizen four there's a bit like in that
film about Edward Snowden sits and for
there's a bit where he's just come out
and he's talking to the journalists or
filmmakers that are making the film it's
kind they can find watching with this
phone you can't leave that like every
he's like in the sort of a state of mad
enlightenment where he's just seen the
truth of they're listening to us now you
can't [ __ ] have that on you like this
it's terrifying to watch on them because
you know obviously now he's calmed down
he's dealt with the understands that you
know but he was like a person that was
emerging from having seen the other side
of the matrix yeah I mean he was deep
into it and then when he revealed all
the information they had a [ __ ] they
were had a manhunt for him the guy had a
hideout in Russia he had a seek asylum
in our enemy yes the whole thing is so
strange
yes so who do our power structures
actually support if someone tells the
truth to the population they have to
flee to Russia if someone talks about
improper agricultural practices that's
against the law they can be in prison
they starts to reveal that the state
itself the very thing that we Revere the
very thing that we identify is the tool
of our oppression who want to discourage
people from leaking information that
makes them look horrible it's that
simple yes it's that simple if you look
at what information he leaked and what
what it did well you know what he did
was revealed things that everyone wanted
to know about yet we felt were crimes it
makes me feel that it's as simple as if
you knew what we do in order to keep
[ __ ]
you would revolt so we are never gonna
let you know well that for me in a sense
is a path the stuffing will hold on
[ __ ] me hell are you I thought you
are elected officials you're one of us
but no you're above us to the point
where someone leaks information about
your crimes
they get locked in this embassy for
seven years like what is their crime
exactly in comparison of the crimes that
he's revealed yes like that's where it's
crazy did the when you look at the the
balance the imbalance between what his
crime is and the crimes that he's
revealed
I mean he's revealed some staggering
crimes and no one's concentrating on
that the government is not freaking out
we've got a we've left some obviously uh
we have work to do we have corrections
to make there's none of that talk
there's get that guy talk yeah that's
right and like it's so under the veil of
patriotism a lot can be concealed and
and that is a incident that passes
through several administrations so like
you mean there for seven years yes it
makes you people what is the what are
the difference is you know like I kinda
you know sort of I been on Bill Maher
show I like Bill Maher I'm I'm you know
very sympathetic to left you know I'm
Alton Utley beyond left left-wing I'm
you know trying to my belief is that we
should trying to organize a system based
on a hallucinogenic experience for
[ __ ] sake there's there's no party for
me and I'm not even allowed to [ __ ]
Hallucigenia and it's safe to say but
like I feel that so many of the problems
that we're experiencing now is because
the the Democratic left-wing liberal
organizations stopped serving the people
they were in the case of the British
Labour Party designed set up to surf
they neglected them they abandoned them
you know they're white weight or the
white working-class in Britain were 50
60 years ago told hey there's this thing
called Britain we want you to go out
there and fight and die for it give up
your sons get out there and now they're
told hey there's no such thing is
Britain and like yeah no wonder people
are confused no wonder people are
baffled no wonder there are abandoned
constituencies and despair and rage and
I I feel the in a way it's like what is
patriotism resourced from a sense that
we all need to belong that we want to be
together
you know that we're willing to believe
in a fictional idea a flag and a story
about the you know the origin of a
nation whether that's an old one like
mine or a new one like this one
you know we're willing to participate in
that but if those values aren't real if
they aren't like if it is we are gonna
support the most powerful we will lie to
you whenever necessary when our lies are
revealed will imprison punish and lie
about those people we don't care about
the most vulnerable what the [ __ ] is the
flag that we're waving who is it for
it's a good point and on that note let's
wrap this [ __ ] up good we went out high
we went that was a good one was a good
way to end it Russell you're awesome man
I love you each other every day you
always like being around you and your
book mentors it's out now your podcast
would be available on luminary starting
25 23rd of this month so just a few days
ladies gentlemen
that's the end of the show
[Music]